Experience
pumped up with caffeine straight off the plane and in traffic.
Cameron Hanes,
slaves and gentlemen.
Good to see you buddy.
Sup Man.
You fucking literally pushed through all night.
Yeah.
It was a,
it was a grind and then the La traffic hall,
dude,
there's something about la traffic that's so frustrating.
More frustrating than even no sleep.
Oh yeah,
I know.
Sleep is fine.
That's gravy.
I do that all the time.
But even today,
trying to get,
I want to get here if want to get here on time.
I hate being late anywhere.
I'm a pretty punctual person.
And this a traffic,
you know,
I was honking to the guy ahead of me just to go 50 feet further cause he's
letting that get,
he's texting me,
he's letting that gap get too big and I'm like okay,
I'm not gonna go anywhere but I'm going to be 50 feet ahead of where we're at.
Yeah,
there's something going on here.
There's too many God damn people.
It's on.
I don't know what the fuck else is going to be like in 10 years.
I came here in [inaudible] 94 so I've been here for 20 years now and when I
first came here it was nothing like this.
Nothing like this.
Traffic sucked,
but it didn't suck like to the point where you're like,
this is just,
this doesn't make sense.
This is just unmanageable.
There's too many God damn people.
Yeah,
it's tough.
And you live in Oregon,
which is like way more relaxed.
He spent all his time in the woods shooting arrows at elk.
The way quieter,
way less people.
The good life.
Good luck.
And now we're forcing you to get on that fucking goofy 101 and get jammed up in
the boxes of metal and fucking breed that carbon dioxide.
It's worth it.
It's worth it to be here.
Of course it is.
Of course it is my friend.
Good to see you again buddy.
Great seeing you.
So what are you doing?
You hanging out with Luke Bryan?
Listen to country music song.
This is mother fucker got me hooked on some country music pop songs.
I know.
I told him,
yes,
we're up blurb bear hunting and watching music videos,
country music.
What are we watching?
Well,
our friends,
John and Jen,
she give them a plug.
I live in the dream.
What is their,
uh,
their website?
Is it live in the dream?
Probably live in the dream.com.
Hold on.
I don't actually have to remember anything anymore.
It Google everything.
I know,
right?
Isn't that amazing?
Live in the dream with John and Jen.
Right?
Something like that.
Yeah,
we'll find it.
Um,
but anyway,
yeah.
Living the dream at John and John live in the dream productions.
That's what it is.
Living the dream productions.com.
And uh,
those are our friends in uh,
in Canada,
up in Alberta.
And that's where we went bear hunting.
And these motherfuckers,
all they listen to is country music.
All they watch is country music,
television.
That's all you need.
So
every day there was me mocking it.
It's just some of it is really good.
I like a lot of country music.
I really do.
Like we had Sturgill Simpson on this week.
I fucking love that guy.
I don't know if you've ever heard Sturgill Simpson.
Now I saw your plugged down.
I was thinking I'm going to check him out.
Oh,
he's good man.
He's real old school like Merle haggard style country music.
He's legit.
Please.
I'm later.
But um,
you guys just won't let it go.
Like there was no,
there was no breakups.
It was just every day there's no,
it didn't like every now and then let's watch yo MTV raps or whatever the fuck
it was.
Just country music,
television over and over again,
being surrounded by deer heads.
You would think that you were in like Alabama somewhere,
but no,
we're two hours north of Edmonton.
Yeah.
In what happened?
What's the moral to the story?
Uh,
I don't know.
Oh,
they got me,
they got me singing that fucking Luke Bryan Song,
man,
play it again.
It's shit.
I,
I was,
I was somewhere,
I forget where it was and it started coming on and I knew the fucking words and
I started humming along and I'm like,
fucking Cam Haynes.
He got me.
Yeah.
They're listening to Luke Bryan skinny,
not your bear.
Yeah.
And that's just,
I don't know,
it just,
it works.
And you,
it's just,
it's etched in your memory.
What is it about country music and outdoors people though?
Because it's like I always associated country music with the south,
but it's a big candidate think too,
like especially northern Canada.
I don't know.
I think it's just uh,
you know,
grassroots people,
hardworking people and uh,
they identify with country music.
Hardworking people can't like ACDC.
No,
it doesn't make any sense.
That's for headbanging possum ogre.
Oh my people.
I've got a bunch of my people in various walks of life.
My people are confused.
They don't know where to go.
You got a lot of appeal to a lot of a wide range now.
Bow Hunters.
Yeah,
I'm mixing it up.
I always say I'm the bridge between the meatheads and the potheads.
I'm the bridge.
I bring them all together.
I'm an island.
Just bow hunters campaigns island.
So you've had a bunch of hunts since I saw you.
You killed two elk.
One in Colorado,
one in Utah.
I saw the pictures.
And you did an Africa hot.
Yeah,
Tanzania.
But you did a real African hunt and I,
one of those pussy ass high fence hunting in a backyard.
No scenarios.
You were out in the wilds of Africa?
Definitely the wilds of Africa.
I was with that Green Leaf Tanzania and it's uh,
you know,
planes don't even fly over there.
This,
this where we were hunting.
No rose,
no anything,
no anything.
I mean to,
to bounce around in a jeep,
it takes you eight hours to cross the,
I guess the piece of property we were hunting and it's very expansive.
Wild.
And when you,
when you bow hunt in these areas,
how often are people bow hunting in these areas or is it mostly rifle hunting
and you just come in and bow hunt,
right it word I where I had been there never been a bowhunter
there.
So bow hunting and Tanzania has only been legal I think for seven years.
And um,
so it's new and when people go there,
it's expensive to get there.
It's time consuming.
Um,
the animals are very tough,
very tough to kill.
So nobody really wants to screw around and making it even harder with a bow.
But,
uh,
that's where I come in.
So that's that.
I was our first bow hunter there ever
for a lot of people know about the controversy that's going on right now.
There's a,
Steve Brunello wrote an excellent piece on this,
uh,
about what's going on in Africa with these a high fence operations where people
are,
it's,
it's a lot of it is people seeing like a pretty girl with like a dead animal and
then freaking out and going off.
And the,
the most recent one wasn't even Africa.
Did you see this kid that shot a,
an albino deer and he's getting death threats?
Yeah.
Just,
yeah.
And it was a nice buck.
Yeah.
It's deer.
It's a fucking deer.
It happens to be white.
Who wouldn't shoot it?
Yeah.
They're like,
you can't let it go.
You can't let it live.
So it can become a,
would ferry and cure cancer a unicorn,
invent six g cellular.
It's just a deer.
It's a deer that has a,
you know,
rare disorder.
One out of every 20,000 deer turned out to be albino.
I guarantee those coyotes or anything else that would like to kill and eat a
deer could care less what color it was.
Yeah,
and or it would have frozen to death or it would have starved.
I mean there's a lot of folks out there just have this idealistic view of what
nature is.
They have this view of nature being this place of peace and harmony and not,
it's a fucking brutal,
horrible environment where no one gets out alive.
All those animals die and they die.
They don't live past like seven or eight years if they're really,
really lucky.
Exactly.
And the idea that there's something wrong with someone stepping in there and
killing one of them and getting the meat off of it as opposed to going to a
supermarket and getting some corralled up penned up animal.
It's lived its life in hell.
It just shows you how goofy we are.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
I know.
We're kind of,
we're talking about Tanzania and now we're talking about me,
but I just,
the other day I put up a picture of me and you with your bear and just the
comments I had from Facebook and he's just like,
one of them that just stuck out to me was,
why would you kill a bear?
I thought bears were endangered.
They're definitely endangered in cities.
They're endangered if I'm around.
But,
but no,
it's,
there's how many bears are there others
where we were.
It's unbelievable how many,
so that,
but that's the,
that's kind of to your point,
people are just so lost.
They just don't get it.
I mean,
bear,
the bear numbers have never been higher than they are right now.
They need to be managing to be hunted and people still think they're endangered
because I guess they don't see,
I'm down here start.
Well,
there's also the anthropomorphizing,
you know,
that,
that that's that uh,
expression where you connect human characteristics to animals like Yogi bear and
you know,
Donald Duck and shit like that.
Like these animals are so fucking ruthless.
The idea that people love bears is so beyond crazy.
While we were there,
uh,
John's son John,
right?
Yeah.
John Sons John to write was Johnson name.
Jonathan.
Yeah.
Jonathan,
uh,
watched,
a bear kill a cub for like attack this female kill the cub,
ate half of it,
then took off the female,
came back and finished off her own cup.
She ate it right?
Like this is the,
these are the animals you're talking about and these are the animals were when
spring rolls around the,
the bears wake up and they go out looking for cubs.
That's what they do.
They go look in the cubs.
I had sue Aiken on the podcast yesterday from that pot,
uh,
life below zero show.
I don't know if you've ever seen that show.
She lives 200 miles north of the Arctic circle and you know,
she's talking about just the bear population in our area and how she was
attacked by a bear and like really fucked up,
bad dislocate her hips,
cracked her skull.
A young male bear attacked her and basically grizzly.
Yeah.
Basically wasn't,
she was like,
if it was older when an Eaton me,
but it just basically kicked my ass and took my territory,
like decided it took her territory so she went back and shot it and killed it.
Perfect.
Yeah.
She's bad ass bitch.
She's by herself in the middle of nowhere.
She's gangster as they come.
But this idea that people have in their head about bears is that the bears,
these peaceful,
you know,
creatures of the forest.
There is some of the most brutal predators and cannibals that we know of in
nature and delicious.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
They're very delicious.
That's the other thing that I got from our trip.
People were like,
why would you eat bear?
What would you be?
Bears are gross.
People don't even eat bear.
That's so not true.
Yeah.
We had some amazing meals up there off the bear.
We killed the gin just cooked up.
I mean,
I remember sitting out there in that plastic table with all of us and just
eating this food bite after bite thinking this is some of the best meat I've
ever had.
And it's very,
really good.
Yeah.
And people have this conception that,
that you can't eat bear bear meat isn't good.
It's just like amazing.
Well,
any meat if you don't prepare it right,
if you don't take care of it after you kill it,
no,
I mean you can get cow meat that rots,
you know,
if you don't take care of it,
if you don't prep it,
if you don't properly cool it and put it on ice or whatever you have to do.
But Jen knows how to cook it.
Yeah.
She did a great job with it.
Oh yeah,
it was good.
But um,
yeah,
like what you're talking about what those boards,
they come out and they kill the cubs.
You know,
I'll,
I'll a big male dominant board cares about is his genetics being passed on.
So when he sees those,
those cubs out there that aren't his,
he's like,
well those aren't my jeans.
So he wants to kill him so that female comes back and heat and then he can breed
her.
And that's the whole thing.
And then as you said,
once that cope,
even that that female is cub was dead.
It went from being her cub when it was dead.
Then it was just,
okay,
it's just more food.
Yeah.
That was a transition and it's just so,
there is no emotion involved in anything.
It's purely survival and purely passing on genes.
Yes,
it
and the numbers are stunning.
When we were up there,
we saw so many bear,
we got to see a bear UFC bout,
remember those to bear that we're going at it because the mail kept coming back
in and the females trying to chase him off.
Me and cam and I were on the ground and were probably like 20 yards from these
bears duking it out.
Yeah.
And they would go,
this one male bear kept sneaking back in.
He kept wanting to to to get to where the bait was and the females trying to
chase him off cause their cubs were there.
Her cubs ran up a tree and she chased him off and he came back and she chased
him off and he came back and then she took off and then she's like,
fuck this.
And she came back in again.
And then they start duking it out.
And when they're duking it out there like
primal.
Oh,
it's so wild.
Because I mean,
this wasn't in a zoo.
I mean,
they could have just said,
you know what?
Fuck this.
Let's go eat those people the right there.
And they just could have just made a mad run for us.
We would have been fucked.
Oh yeah.
Well,
and you know,
you mentioned the bait there and that's another thing people don't really
understand because baiting,
um,
gets a black eye sometimes,
for hunting,
but up there,
it's really the only way to control those bare numbers.
There's so many bear,
they kill so many Moose.
That country is so thick and if you're going to hunt them,
you have to bring him to you somehow and be able to kill him.
And if you didn't bait,
you would probably never kill a bear up there.
The only time you would get one is maybe you would get the fall bears that were
eating the berries right on the hills where you could see them.
But the,
the thickness of the forest,
I compare it to like a box of Q tips,
right?
It's like you're not seeing anything 30,
40 yards in,
you're not seeing shit.
It's just all trees.
It's so dense.
And,
and another key to baiting and seeing those bear up close is identifying what
you're killing because you want to take out those dominant males that have
already bred,
that are older,
past their prime.
And that's what we're trying to kill up there.
We're not taking,
um,
sounds with cubs.
We're not taking young males that are,
haven't reached,
you know,
John and Jen,
what they liked,
they liked to kill seven foot plus black bear.
So to do that,
you know,
people look at bear and all bear looked the same to the uneducated I,
well,
once you,
when you can see him up close,
how,
how we were hunting them on the ground,
you get a real good idea of what you're shooting.
What's your hunting,
which you're going to pass up.
And that's,
that's a key too.
So it's just,
it's just,
um,
it's wildlife management at its best.
Really?
Yeah.
That's the best way to
put it.
Wildlife Management and the number of people that even hunt other animals are
kind of a bit ignorant to it.
Like there was folks that Jen was telling us that some local moose hunters
where,
uh,
giving her a hard time and she was like,
do you understand that the majority of these moose calves are getting killed by
bears?
Right.
Like the majority,
like,
right.
Like when they're out of their mother,
like that bear smells that and starts looking for him.
Yeah.
It's like,
I mean,
and that's nature.
That's,
that's what,
what's what,
what happens out?
Can't blame the,
be the bear.
No,
I was just being a bear.
But you can control their numbers and help the Mousse.
Yeah.
I couldn't help think about grizzly man though when we were out there.
I'm like,
David,
how fucking I'm making fun of this Timothy Treadwell guy like on a daily basis
here on the ground,
stand next to his bow hunting maniac who only hunts on the ground.
He doesn't want to go up in Trieste dance cause that's for pussies.
I,
you know,
I just like being,
I don't know,
I liked that connection with the animal on the ground.
Yeah,
it's a connection.
I mean it,
it can be real and it can be very intense as you experienced,
but there's nothing like it for me.
It's very wild,
very wild.
Um,
it's a,
it's a totally different kind of hunting because just the sheer numbers and you
just really do see a lot of bear.
And John was saying that he thinks in his area where he hunts,
there is somewhere between three and eight bear per square mile,
which is a lot.
I mean that is a lot of animals.
Yeah.
Now there's a,
you know,
people are used to seeing quite a few deer,
quite a few elk.
Maybe if they live in the right country,
white deal,
dear specialty.
That's how bear are back back there.
It's just amazing.
Yeah,
it's a really wild place.
Albert is amazing.
So beautiful.
It's just so thick with wilderness and trees and it's just so much wildlife up
there.
So much cool shit to say.
Yeah.
And that's,
to me,
that's the big,
not not,
I mean that's one,
one more draw for hunting is when you're just driving through country and you're
just kind of in the cities and you're driving around maybe in a car,
you don't get to experience what that country is.
I mean to be out there to live it to,
uh,
you know,
when I go to the,
all these places,
Tanzania,
Alberta,
Australia,
and I live out there and sit on the ground and see the animals and,
and,
and hunt them,
what one on one.
That's when you really get to experience everything that country has to offer.
And that's,
that's so valuable.
I mean,
people,
that connection has made me who I am,
whether I'm killing anything or not.
Just being there and just being part of part of the country.
It's,
it's a,
I don't know.
It's amazing.
Yeah,
it's definitely something that we're completely disconnected to by standing in
the one on one traffic over and over and over again and just grinding out every
week.
The sort of the same way you start this becomes life.
It becomes life.
It becomes,
this is life.
Life is you get up,
you,
your alarm clock goes off,
you got an hour commute and you really should be about a three minute commute,
but you're going to get stuck in traffic.
And when you go to a place like Alberta and you're,
you're out there and just,
just unbelievably beautiful,
dense forest and you're out there and you're out there doing something that
requires a tremendous amount of discipline to the,
one of the things that I really enjoy about,
uh,
archery and about bow hunting is it's not as easy as like set up.
I'm not saying that rifle hunting is easy because it's debt.
None of it is easy,
but it's not.
If you have a good rest for your rifle,
you know,
and the animals no more than,
a hundred yards away,
he is pretty good likelihood that you're going to shoot that animal a hundred
yards away with a bone out.
Good fucking luck.
Just started.
Yeah.
You're,
you're,
you know,
most likely you're not going to hit that thing that's really fucking far.
No,
that's,
you know,
cause I rifle hunted for three years before I started bow hunting and uh,
what I started rifle hunting.
I loved it.
I loved the challenge.
I still love going out on rifle Hans.
I haven't rifle hunter for 26 years,
but I just like the hunting atmosphere and environment and,
and working together.
But what I notice when I transitioned from rifle hunting to bow hunting is where
the rifle hunt ended.
Like,
as you said,
a hundred yards,
200 yards,
where that,
where it ended,
it was over.
If you made the shot game over,
that's where the bell hunt really begins.
So you,
you're a hundred yards or 200 yards and now you gotta be on your a game.
You're now getting from there to the red zone or bow range of an animal.
That's where it starts to get.
That's where it's difficult
for you.
Comfortable is like 60 yards in.
Is that where it's comfortable for you?
Yeah,
I like him at eight yards,
but uh,
yeah,
I mean I practice a lot.
Um,
I've very comfortable I can make the shot at 60 yeah,
it's just a different discipline.
Archery is,
and one of the things that I've talked about with some of my friends that have
really gotten into archery is about how the world sort of goes away when you're
focusing on the bullseye.
It's a weird zen state and it really,
in that sense,
the practice for someone who has no interest in hunting,
maybe you're a vegetarian.
I totally respect that that's what you want to do.
But archery in and of itself is an amazing pursuit.
Just like for the meditative aspects of it.
There's something about archery.
I would go,
I screwed my shoulder up,
man.
You eat too much,
shooting too much.
I was doing a hundred 150 hours a day after the moon.
After the bear hunt,
I've got a little fucking crazy and I developed a little tendinitis in my
shoulder.
The on the bear hunt,
if you,
if you recall,
I don't know how many bowl hundreds we had.
We had maybe six bow hunters up there,
but you shot at least double more than anybody else.
I mean,
so you,
you like shooting the ball obviously,
but then you ramped it up after that.
Yeah,
I,
I liked,
I was doing more than anybody because first of all,
you know,
there was a,
I felt like a real obligation to make an accurate shot and I wanted to be 100%
prepared.
And I'm,
I'm a big stickler on preparation.
No matter what I do,
if it's martial arts,
if it's comedy,
any,
anything I do,
I prepare the shit out of things and I,
I'm,
I'm an obsessive compulsive in that way.
So even like when we were all hanging,
everybody was hanging around,
joking and laughing.
I was like,
I could be shooting more hours,
so I would just go off and start shooting arrows.
What everybody else was goofing off.
I just had to,
it's,
you know,
it's been maybe if people could even misconstrued as being antisocial,
but I just had to do it and I had to get those arrows in.
Yeah.
I,
the way I perceived it was,
that was it.
That was your first ever bow hunt and you just wanted to do everything you could
to make,
to really,
we're trying to kill an animal ethically and quickly.
And so I know you took and take a lot of responsibility and that,
and our role as a steward of the land and the animals.
And so got to make that shot.
You know,
it happens so fast.
Even,
even if you're hunting,
bear in a controlled environment,
it's with a bow at is still tough.
It's still tough.
So,
I mean,
I,
uh,
slit you for your commitment.
They're practicing and you made a great shot on your bare.
Yeah,
it was perfect.
Yeah.
It died in seconds and that's what I wanted.
I wanted it to just be,
oh,
and also it's beautiful having a friend like you who could talk me through all
that stuff,
who can talk me through the right way to prepare and all the right equipment.
Having the right bow,
you know,
you get people give you a hard time because you,
you shoot really powerful bows and they're like,
you don't need to shoot a Bogo.
Powerful you down.
I'm just retarded.
Why would I shoot that?
That's stupid.
Well,
the idea being that the more powerful the bow,
the,
the more impact the Arrow has and the more it can penetrate into an animal.
It just makes sense.
But not everybody has cam Haynes guns.
That's what's up,
you know,
uh,
that is a real pet.
I feel bad sometimes because sometimes,
you know,
I'll talk about my bow and then out of the blue somebody says,
why do you need to shoot 80 or 90 pounds?
And I've heard it for years,
probably thousands of times.
And I just feel like lashing out at that one person who maybe that was the first
time they've ever even been on my Facebook page or whatever,
that that's what's happened the other day.
And I didn't,
I didn't lash out because I don't,
you know,
I try to respect everybody.
I don't,
whatever,
I've just tried to be respectful.
And so all I said to that guy was,
uh,
you know,
he says he's killed all these animals that got pastors with 62 pounds.
Okay.
I said,
all right,
well what,
what about the guys who shoot 50 pounds?
They'd probably say to you,
why do you shoot 62 pounds?
I shoot 50 and kill my animals.
So they would say,
you're doing too much.
And my whole thing is I pro,
I hope for the best,
prepare for the worst.
And so,
um,
the worst is on a big bull elk.
You catch your shoulder blade or you drill a big heavy rib or from Hunting Cape
Buffalo,
um,
I hit a rib,
which is like a two by four.
So I'm preparing for the worst,
I hope for the best.
You know,
if you think in almost any bow with a razor sharp broadhead,
if is just hitting soft flesh between the ribs is going to kill it.
You could probably do that with 40 pounds,
maybe even 30 some pounds,
but you're hoping for the,
the very best situation.
It's not going to happen every time.
It's probably going to be rare.
So that's my whole thing.
Prepare for the worst hope for the [inaudible].
Well,
it's interesting is that you've got a whole group of people that are sort of
following philosophy now.
Like this whole,
you know,
your,
your uh,
your catchphrase.
Keep hammering.
Yeah.
I see all this Hashtag keep hammering people in the gym preparing for bow hunts.
It's like people prepare for bow hunts now.
Like they're preparing for an athletic event.
I see these dudes doing all of these rows and lifts and Chin ups and pulling
their back muscles and getting everything in order and then running up hills and
all following your lead and treating this as like an athletic endeavor.
If you've ever seen it.
Actually did we,
we didn't play your,
your under armor commercial the first time.
Do we,
did we play it the wolf?
Did we play that commercial?
We say if we did,
we probably did.
I love that fucking commercial.
But that commercials the perfect,
it's like it shows you preparing,
you know,
running up hills and that's also part of this,
this bow hunting thing is that you're preparing for an event as much of an event
as a marathon,
as much of an event.
And maybe even more so because it's this,
you know,
people don't like the,
the term spiritual when it's connected to hunting,
but there is something that's very spiritual about taking an animal,
respecting it's alive,
taking out that meat and then eating it.
And this feeling that you have of being connected to this cycle of life,
it's a very,
very different thing than anything I've ever done before.
Anything I've ever done where,
um,
especially anything that you've ever done where you've eaten meat and meat,
do you ever eaten meat from a store or meat from a restaurant?
There's a complete wall up between you and the process and the bow hunting part
is like one more step closer.
It's like there's the rifle thing but then the bow hunting thing is one more
step.
Yeah,
this is,
this is in the under Armour one though.
Brandon shocky did this on this is but this,
that's,
that's the training part definitely.
Yeah.
There,
there is a different one.
There's an under armor commercial but that one's cool to too,
but you could,
you could see the amount of preparation that's involved in in this and so you
know this is a lot of people out there that are like really into crossfit and
they're really into like working out and you are and I am and like I had this
dude who was on fear of fact and wants him and his girlfriend.
Nice folks.
They were crossfit people and I was like well what do you do?
Like with all that exercise you just exercise and for exercise,
you know like it's good to be in shape and everything like that.
Why don't you take up Jujitsu or something like that?
Go put it to use,
like see progress in an athletic endeavor.
Yeah.
Well one of the best and ultimate ways is hunting because you,
you're putting that progress,
you're putting that athleticism and that training and that all that hard work.
You're putting it into this really primal situation where you're going uphill
hill.
Especially like the elk hunting,
which I can't wait to get up,
get a part of next year.
Yeah.
We're going to go bow hunting for elk next year.
That seems to me like probably the ultimate of though.
Yeah.
The,
I think the thing with elk,
for me that's a,
that's been,
we've probably mentioned that before because if anybody who's going to talk to
me about bow hunting is Alex going to come up.
Um,
that was always that the biggest dream was killing a big bull elk with my boat.
And it's so hard.
It is so difficult.
And,
uh,
it,
you know,
I killed a bull elk my very first year of bow hunting.
I think I was 19 and,
um,
I killed a spike bull.
Took a long time to do it.
Um,
but when I said,
okay,
I want to kill now a mature big bowl,
six by six in the wilderness by myself,
that took eight years to do eight years of bow hunting to ever I killed other
bowls.
I killed some five points,
a few,
five points,
another spike,
um,
a six by five.
But it took me eight years to get that quote,
Dream Bull and to anybody at to,
to I guess a seasoned,
I dunno,
a trophy hunter.
It,
they probably wouldn't even a shot it,
but it was a nice six by six,
scored about 275 inches,
pope and young.
And uh,
it was a wilderness on my own and that took eight years.
So it's,
it's a tough deal
when you have a wilderness hunt on your own and you shoot this animal,
you're miles away from civilization.
Yeah.
You just hike it back in steps one at a time.
Well,
with that bowl,
at that time I owned with my buddy Roy,
um,
for llamas.
And so we would train these llamas and Aloma isn't like a horse.
Um,
but they can pack 60 pounds.
So four of them,
you got 240 pounds of meat you can haul out or gear or whatever else.
So on that hunt,
I had four lamas available.
The problem was I killed that bull opening day of the season.
We had just walked in with those lamas with me and these other guys.
I was by myself about 10 miles away cause I liked,
I didn't,
I like to be by myself.
I mean right now I just kind of tolerate the camera man and you know,
if I'm with somebody,
but really what,
I'm drawn to his solo hunting on my own just because just the,
I just liked the test of that.
So anyway,
I was by myself.
I killed his bull is opening day,
I skinned it out,
got it hung up.
And in that high country I killed it as probably about over 7,000 feet.
So even though it was September and it was warm in the evenings at 7,000 feet or
at night it gets cool.
The air is dry.
So if you hang that meet up like in a north facing timber where the sun stays
off of it and it stays cooler in there and he'd get up off the ground where the
wind can move,
uh,
you can get what,
what hunters called the meat would glaze over.
So it basically cools glazes over.
And I've had even in,
in,
um,
early season like that I could,
you could hang a deer and elk for five days and the meat would be fine.
And so what I did with that is I broke that all down and I'm like,
well,
I'll go see how the lawn mowers are doing.
I packed all the way back long was because we just came in the day before.
We're too tired there.
They're only about 300 pounds.
So it's not like they got a ton of muscle.
They'd walked 12 miles in with gear and I knew they couldn't get that bull out.
So I waited for these other guys who were hunting 10 miles away from me that
night to come back to camp.
And I'm like,
guys,
I said,
I killed a bull.
If,
uh,
if you guys help me get it out,
you know,
we'll go down to la grand.
I'll get us a hotel room,
I'll buy us pizza,
Dah,
do this whole thing.
I was like,
it would do anything.
And so me and three other guys packed that whole bowl out,
12 miles,
took it to the meat locker there and then packed back in and 12 miles with how
many,
how big was the bull?
Is that,
is that first six by six bullet killed?
So we probably had,
I don't know,
there's probably 240 pounds of me.
250 pounds a meter,
you know,
split up.
So I mean,
that's it.
Yeah,
that's an enormous animals.
So we were talking about like 1200 pounds on the hook for something like that.
No,
that one was probably 800 800.
And what's the like the biggest one you've ever seen?
The biggest bull I've ever killed was in 2010 it was a Roosevelt Bolen,
Oregon.
I was with my buddy,
uh,
Jodi Cyr.
He called that or I think he would know he was filming and then Kevin Acres was
calling just,
we all grew up bow hunting there in Oregon,
just,
you know,
kind of bow hunting,
rednecks from I guess the Bush of Oregon.
And so we got this bull in and I ended up killing it.
And uh,
it was,
you know,
we're thinking 1100 pounds.
It was just a giant six by six,
uh,
old 12 or 13 year old bowl.
And uh,
that's a biggest body bullet ever seen.
Elk is interesting too because the old animals still tastes delicious.
Yeah.
And I'm not sure.
Yeah,
because
like deer,
you can get like a ruddy old buck that's like a eight,
nine year old buck and it's like,
Whoa,
you might need to throw this one in the steam cooker crock pot or something.
You know,
that was like those,
you know,
that water buffalo or a couple of my killed in Australia,
they were,
they can get old.
The Cape Buffalo I killed in Tanzania.
Dude,
that meat,
I mean,
in Tanzania with that Cape Buffalo,
we use that for Lion Bait.
I mean it's just not good meat cause those bulls are so old and so tough and
it's just,
you know,
if he had needed,
I guess you could,
I'm sure the natives there would definitely eat it.
Yeah.
We just make carpaccio out of it.
And that she would like Turkey I guess.
I don't know,
be like a Cape Buffalo steak.
Good luck.
Right?
Yeah.
Dan's ass animal.
No,
but you know,
so I killed a kudu that was excellent meat.
A sable,
they're beautiful meat who's,
who's supposed to be one of the best.
Right?
Yeah.
I mean,
and sable to yeah.
Just uh,
yeah,
there's a lot of those animals,
a lot of good eating animals are not just not buffalo.
The controversy about African animals is,
um,
I mean you get what I call Facebook controversy,
which is very,
uh,
sort of cursory controversy.
Like it's not people that are really investigating it and trying to figure out
what is going on here.
They just see a picture of a pretty girl from Texas with a,
with an animal on the ground and they go,
oh,
that pitch and Rinella wrote this article,
which is really interesting where he was saying that a lot of what you're
dealing with is just trade up sexism.
Yeah.
You're dealing with people that don't want to see a pretty girl in that
environment and for whatever reason they need to decide it's not her place or
especially because she's pretty,
they have some certain amount of resentment about her anyway because she carries
around a certain amount of privilege and you know,
easy access to life because she's so pretty doors just open up for which is
true,
right?
Yeah.
But what people,
what they fail to do is really sort of investigate what's going on in Africa in
that these people that live in these communities,
if it wasn't for these high fence hunting operations,
their resources would be severely diminished.
Yeah.
They're making so much more money because the money that comes in from tags from
hunters,
and there's an industry there now and it's kind of a fucked up thing to say to a
lot of people like,
hey,
there's an industry in killing animals.
Yeah.
But that industry has served two purposes.
One,
those animals are in gigantic healthy populations now where they're on the verge
of extinction just a couple decades ago.
Right?
Yeah.
And it's uh,
yeah,
hunting there.
I mean,
especially,
you know,
the high fence thing,
that's,
that's a whole nother thing.
That's basically,
I guess you could,
it's close to farming.
It is really close to as farming animals.
Um,
but it is industry there.
It is a way for locals to make money and be involved and,
and generate income for their family.
So I mean,
how do you,
who am I to judge that?
I can't,
um,
in Tanzania there's even less so that most,
the high fence hunting is in South Africa and Tanzania and the,
in the Bush way back there,
there is even less opportunity for those people.
There's no food or not.
I mean,
there's limited food,
but no power,
no water,
grass shacks or huts.
It's,
uh,
you know,
I,
it's real poverty.
It's,
yeah.
Poverty on an intense scale that I think us as Americans,
we,
you know,
you dip your toes in,
you go visit for a little bit and you're still not really grasping the idea of
being born there now with no opportunity to get out.
I don't see how you ever could,
you know,
but what's weird,
and so I was wrestling with this whole time because when I go to these places,
I love the culture.
I love the people.
Um,
even there as trying to learn Swahili with some of the,
um,
the trackers that we're working with me.
Uh,
Rashidi awesome guy speaks only Swahili,
but I,
so I really invest myself into the culture and I just want to learn.
I want to sorta get,
I want to see things through their eyes.
Well,
I saw these grass shacks and all these people in the,
you know,
every grass shack had six little kids running around it.
And it was just like,
I'm thinking this is awful.
I mean,
it's no hope for six kids at every grass shack that seems,
I don't know,
it just seemed very sad to me.
But we were there getting ready to cross this river in the truck and the river
was high,
so we were kind of out,
uh,
Ryan Shalom is the,
he's,
uh,
he owns Greenleaf,
Tanzania.
And so we're,
we're there and we're kind of seeing what's going on.
And there was a village about a quarter mile away.
And,
uh,
as we're looking at the river and trying to make a game plan,
there was music and just people singing.
And I'm like,
is it happy hour here?
What is going on?
And it just,
that really just hit home.
It's like,
you know,
I see him and I think there's no hope and they must be miserable.
But they're laughing and singing and dancing.
Maybe.
Maybe they're okay.
I don't know.
I mean,
are they happy?
They seemed happy to me,
so I don't really cause,
so it's weird.
It's,
you know,
I don't know.
I can,
I can look at it from outside and judge and say,
Oh,
you know,
you must be so depressed.
Maybe they're not.
Yeah.
Well I think people are incredibly adaptable.
And um,
when people grow up in an environment that's just what they're used to,
you get,
you get used to it and that's how you live.
And if that's all you know,
you know,
you don't know what it's like to stay at the four seasons and eat at the buffet
in the morning and you know,
have the valet pull your car around all the shit,
you know,
some
people think is the good life,
but those people that are living like that at the four seasons,
you know,
checking their Rolex,
where is this Goddamn Valet?
I know those people might be on fucking antidepressants.
People in Africa is singing and playing the Bongo drums and having a great old
time.
You know,
what would cause the people at the four seasons the most heartache?
What?
The fricking Wifi wasn't working.
Yes.
So God damn,
why Fi's pulse shit.
You know,
I tried to get a kudu stake this morning.
You don't even have Kudu.
Yeah.
W W we,
we think that this is the only way to,
let me look.
Life is about friendship experience,
having fun and staying healthy and whatever those people can do to make that
happen and what whatever is in their environment that they can take advantage of
as far as like,
you know,
nutrition and you know,
being able to take care of their family,
you know,
they do what they can with what they've got.
And that's also something where the hunters help out.
And this is off often been criticized as just like all people,
just using that as an excuse and that a lot of the meat goes to these families
and these villages and it is a huge,
huge benefit to them to get fresh protein like,
um,
like Brian Stevens that we were talking to when we were on that hunt was talking
to me about an elephant killed.
They had,
yeah,
they killed an elephant and you,
and you talk about killing an elephant and everybody goes,
oh my God,
you killed an elephant.
How the fuck could you kill an elephant?
I don't have any desire to kill an elephant,
but I wanted to listen to his perspective and see what he had to say about it.
Well,
one of the things that he was saying was that when you kill an elephant,
the village,
they all pile in to get a piece of that health and so welcome like this,
these photos of these people with these just great baskets filled with elephant
meet and there's dozens and dozens of people taking this meat away and this is
protein that they wouldn't ordinarily not have been able to get.
Then you've,
you're dealing with the money that this guy had to pay to harvest itself and
which is a substantial amount of money.
I think it's like 30 or $50,000 can be.
Yeah.
And then you're dealing with the reality that in these certain circumstances,
in some of these places they have a population problem.
People don't want to think that they think that elephants are endangered.
They are in some places.
Yeah.
But Africa is fucking huge.
It is a huge,
huge,
huge continent.
So if they have an issue in one area where they don't have very many elephants,
it doesn't mean the entire place is,
you know,
has a,
a lack of animals.
No,
no.
And you know,
one thing I was,
I was fascinated with,
you know,
we,
we had to deal with poachers when I was back there in Tanzania and,
and most of the poachers we dealt with were simply what they,
they call us after protein all there,
they're up there,
they're killing buffalo,
they're killing.
So I say we wouldn't want you to buffalo.
They will gladly take a buffalo but a,
so they go up there and we ran across
three poachers at one time.
Usually there's a shooter and two packers.
And what they do is they kill an animal.
They live up there.
They,
they cut it up,
they dry it out,
and then all their packing out,
all this meat with is a burlap sack with like wire straps.
So wire through the burlap.
And then they load that up with this dried out meat,
which I don't know even know what it would weigh at that time.
But that's how they get it out and they're not selling that.
They might sell the protein when they get out,
but it's just meat.
It's not like this high level poaching operation.
Right.
So ivory or something and they're willing to get that meat.
They're willing to shoot you and the game scout who were we were with is willing
to shoot them.
A lot of times it's whoever can shoot first and that's,
that's,
that was a eye opening experience.
I mean,
you know,
we have somebody,
you just don't do that here.
It's just,
it's just different to there.
It's just like whoever can shoot first.
And that one that the first guy that we saw didn't shoot at us because he didn't
have any ammo.
He had to basically load his gun like a muzzleloader as a rifle.
But he had,
I found their camp and we investigated everything they had in their camp.
And so we had like ball bearings and pieces of lead and thinks he would shove
down the barrel and he had wadding and he had uh,
a firing pin mache heads to ignite it gunpowder.
And so basically he would get one shot and to get that one shot,
he had to be close.
So that's why he didn't shoot at us.
We were at about a hundred and some yards.
He ended up circling around getting to 50 yards and he's just standing there,
but he only knew he only had one shot.
So anyway,
the whole point is they're willing to risk their lives to get protein.
Now we did find a dead,
there was an elephant skull there.
And so just had me,
you know,
curious as to how that works.
I said,
so obviously somebody came in here and poach this elephant.
What,
how much are they getting for that ivory?
You know,
and,
and so we figured maybe a 20 or 30 year old elephant is,
they say would 50 pounds of ivory.
Just roughly.
It could have more,
could have less,
um,
50 pounds of ivory.
So for 50 pounds of ivory a poacher,
we'll get $250 wow.
$250 I was thinking maybe they're going to get thousands of dollars,
$250 whereas,
you know,
you mentioned Brian Stevens and the elephant hunt that Americans would go on or,
or you know,
a,
a hunter that would pay for it and they're paying upward maybe $50,000 so you're
trading the life of an animal.
If it's poached for 250 or if a hunter goes over there to hunt it and the meat
is utilized by the whole village,
$50,000.
Now what helps a community more?
Yeah,
well it certainly helps the community more if a hundred pays.
But the real question that have is why does
a hundred want to do that?
Why would someone want to go over and shoot an elephant?
And I kind of see their point of view.
Like what,
what is it about an,
why would you want to go over there and shoot this big magnificent animal?
Why couldn't you just go over there and enjoy looking at it?
Right.
Um,
good question.
You know,
I guess,
uh,
for me,
I can't
relate to an elephant and I've never,
I've never really thought about killing an elephant or even pursued the
opportunity,
but I want to kill a lion.
I went over there to kill an African lion with my bow and,
uh,
people,
same question,
why?
And to me,
to me,
the reason why I do what I do every day is a test.
And I feel like if I'm going after that
King of the jungle,
so to speak,
or Simba with my bow,
that's the ultimate test.
And I mean,
if you're not testing yourself or for me,
if I'm not testing myself,
what's the point?
But then,
okay,
so here's the argument.
People would be like,
you fucking asshole.
Why do you want to go over there and shoot a lion?
Lions,
a beautiful majestic animal.
It's the king of the jungle.
Why would you want to shoot it?
You're not even going to eat it,
but you are going to eat it.
Yeah.
No.
And you should see it's such a,
I don't know,
there there's a connection with the,
the natives of the Tanzania is over there,
right.
Are
we were in,
if any cat has killed.
And when I was there,
um,
one of the guys I was with Richard Bucca,
he killed a leopard and when,
uh,
any cat is killed or an elephant,
the whole village or all the guys that were there working,
you basically stop in the jeep up on the hill.
They get the jeep all put brush all over it and they have this chant and they,
they sing this chant as you drive down,
they shoot the gun twice to announce to the hunting camp that were coming in.
And we got a special animal.
And uh,
you know,
Ryan explained this whole thing to me.
Um,
but we've got a special animal and so it's either a cat or an elephant and they
come in and it's just,
it's the biggest celebration.
When Richard killed that leopard,
they all,
all the guys there,
the,
the Tanzania there were singing this chant and it was just,
it was so powerful.
And they had him,
he sat in this chair and they lifted it up in this chair and we're carrying them
around the camp.
That was for,
to honor the life of the,
the leopard and four in lions,
or even one step above for them.
Simba is,
they have so much reverence and respect for a lion.
It's,
uh,
you know,
I,
I couldn't even really understand it.
Only they could probably explain it,
but it says no,
that when that animal dies,
it's not just,
you're just killing an animal is to kill an animal.
There's,
there's a lot,
there's a lot of,
there's a connection that goes into,
uh,
the animals valuable.
The animal was a just revered.
And,
um,
and um,
I assume they also have to keep the populations down.
Yeah.
That's,
uh,
you know,
lion hunting is,
I mean,
a lot of people look at Lyons and judge the Hunting Forum saying what?
And there might be a time when there is no more lion hunting just because of the
of public outcry basically.
But as it is now,
Ryan were Schlom where I was hunting with Greenleaf.
Um,
I had the opportunity,
we could have killed.
We had in it bait a four year old lions,
male legal,
big manes by themself,
definitely could kill him.
He wants to,
he wants to let those four year olds age to s six or greater.
He only wants to kill six year old lions are greater because then they're past
their prime passer breeding pot prime.
They've done their job for the population,
so to speak.
And that's when he'll take 'em out.
And not before,
even though it's legal,
but um,
just to build that pride up.
And then another thing that they'll,
um,
he does is if a male lion is with a pride,
so meaning there's females there and there's cubs there that if he's there with
them,
they're his cubs.
Otherwise he'd kill him just like the bare,
same,
same type of deal.
But he would never kill a male lion that had a pride or is even close to a pride
that,
um,
because what that would do if you kill the male,
even though it's legal,
um,
what that would do is another mail would come in.
So the mail,
you killed his dad,
another mail would come in.
Those wouldn't be his cubs.
So he would kill them.
So you'd have two generations alliance gone.
And so part of his management practice there is,
um,
only old lions,
only old loan lions,
male lions.
And that's it.
So you're basically catching a line at the end of his run.
That's it.
Once they're,
they're not breathing anymore,
it's,
they've done their job.
Basically.
The only value they have now is for a hunter.
The only value,
but there's still there a life.
There are life.
They're living creature,
a majestic living creature.
And that's definitely,
that's where people have the issue.
Right.
Do you try to look at it from their point of view ever?
Do you ever say like,
like the,
the anti hunting people like anti honey,
people fall into a bunch of different categories.
There's people who don't think you should eat any meat at all.
That's the super extreme.
Then there's people who can respect you,
eating animals that were raised in an ethical way,
free range,
cows,
free range chickens,
and the only way I would do it,
that's it.
That's some group.
And then there's people that say,
well,
I really respect people who go out and hunt their own meat.
But as you get like deeper and deeper into the,
you know,
the,
the categories of,
of people that have problems with hunting at the very top of that list,
which is like the most
hated,
is people that hunt only for the trophy trophy.
Yeah.
And that's what a lot of people think of when they think of elephant.
A lot of people think of when they think of lion,
and I have no desire to shoot anything.
I'm not going to eat it.
Never will.
I just,
it's not,
my goal with getting into hunting was to connect with the food that I eat to try
to figure out,
I mean,
when I've,
when I first hunted with Rinella,
I was wondering,
I was like,
what if I shoot this deer and say,
fucking,
I'm a vegetarian now.
I'm never doing this again.
Yeah.
It was the exact opposite,
right?
Like,
I've,
I've felt like an immediate,
incredible connection to is very exciting and thrilling and people don't want to
hear you say that.
They want to hear it like a very somber moment.
Yeah.
But I mean,
look,
there's Hbo Real Sports Air to the other night.
There's this thing where,
uh,
they did this,
this whole piece on hunting and this whole a eat what you kill movement with
what they called it.
And they had the clip of me shooting my first deer and I,
you know,
I kind of forgot like how,
like I was pretty emotional when it happened.
Yeah.
So there's,
there's definitely a sense of loss when something like that happens,
but it's not,
it's not sad,
you know?
That's,
that's an animal that I wanted to eat,
you know,
but,
but there's a difference between that and just going after some animal just to
shoot it.
And it was just,
I needed to get this on my list and I want to have,
I have a fucking,
I have a basketball court in my house filled with dead animals and you know,
this is my next one.
Right.
Yeah,
that's true.
You know,
and,
and I guess what I'm thinking about it when I leave and God judged when you
killed your bear because we had a picture of a smiling with the dead bear and,
uh,
you know,
I have a hard time,
the people on the fence who needed to be convinced or,
or it could go either way.
Those are the people I can appeal to and maybe make an argument that,
you know,
how hard I work and how much hunting means to me and how much I respect these
animals,
those people,
the extreme people.
You're,
I don't think you're ever going to win those guys over.
No,
I don't think so.
He's a whatever.
That's just a lost cause.
But the,
the other ones,
that's why,
you know,
and I've,
I've posted this before when I,
when I had,
when I kill an animal,
I don't want a bunch of blood and hunters have said bloods part of it.
Why?
Why are you worried about showing blood?
Well,
because I don't want to offend the people who might be in the middle,
you know what I mean?
But when you get judged,
we got judged for smiling because with your dead bear.
Yeah.
Um,
the reason why I'm,
yeah,
when the animals,
I guess it's not,
I don't feel sad,
but I respect when an animal dies.
But the smiling part is,
I'm proud of everything that went into how much work is involved and how much
sacrifice.
You know,
when you killed yours,
you made and that's just,
it's a celebration.
You killed an animal.
We're going to eat it.
All that months and months of work paid off.
That should feel good.
There's nothing wrong with,
hey,
we're celebrating this moment.
It's such a special cherished moment
with smile.
Well,
this is the weird,
the weirdness of modern civilization is that no one has a problem with you
smiling when you're eating a cheeseburger.
If you look at it,
any burger king ad,
any Mcdonald's ad,
when someone's eating,
ah,
big smile on their face,
maybe you're eating a fucking animal.
It lived its life in torture,
right?
I mean there's very little possibility that that animal was a free range animal.
That animal most likely it was corralled up,
was fed and unnatural diet to fatten it up was stuffed full of antibiotics to
deal with the fact that it was fed this unnatural die because it would otherwise
get sick.
All sorts of indigestion problems,
stomach problems,
and that's what you're eating with a big stupid smile on your face.
And no one bats an eye,
right?
The,
I had a,
I wrote a blog post and I still haven't put up yet cause I dealt with so many
fucking idiots getting mad at me after I shot that bear.
But one of them was this guy at the airport,
um,
who had seen the picture of us.
You were arrogant.
You remember that?
Oh yeah,
that was a lady
that was a good story.
Actually.
W Cam and I were on the plane and there was a gentleman who was a flight
attendant that was a little bit light in the loafers.
Uh,
he was perhaps a gay man.
let's just say 100%.
He was a gay man,
a very nice gay man.
He was very friendly and he was really cool and we were having fun with the guy.
We were,
you know,
he was just,
it was just being a friendly guy,
but he kept complimenting Cam's arms.
Cam's a very athletic and muscular man.
He works out a lot.
He's got a lot of veins in his arms and stuff.
And this guy kept calling them muscles and he's like,
you know,
how would he say it though?
He's like muscles.
He was so flamboyant.
I mean,
he was a great guy.
He was just super,
super nice guy.
Don't get me wrong.
So anyway,
he,
he just kept complimenting cam and what do you do?
What do you do?
And he's like,
well,
you know,
I'm workout and stuff.
I bet you too.
I bet you do.
I mean,
it was fun.
It was fun.
Totally lighthearted.
So as we're leaving,
I said to Kim,
I go,
if that guy doesn't at least smack you on the ass on the way out,
I'm going to be very disappointed.
That's all I said.
And so we're waiting for our luggage.
And this woman came up to me,
then he goes,
he didn't,
by the way,
didn't really sad.
I mean I felt like you guys had a connection.
I kind of tensed up and I walked back cause I was getting ready,
but it was just me and cam having fun.
And it wasn't mean spirited at all.
We were talking,
we were sitting by each other talking to each other and talking like at this
level.
It wasn't like we were yelling out back
on it.
I think he's gay.
They don't care.
It was US having a private conversation behind us happen to be a lesbian,
I'm assuming a lesbian and her girlfriend.
And uh,
when we're waiting for the luggage,
the woman started giving me a hard time.
Just con call me arrogant.
Here's so arrogant.
I go,
how am I arrogant?
She goes,
she goes,
that man was a nice man.
I go,
he's a very nice man,
and she goes,
you,
I heard what you said about him slapping your friend in the ass.
I go,
he was flirting with my friend.
first of all,
it's not arrogant.
My friend's a handsome man one way,
flirting.
Let's not,
I don't want this one way.
Absolutely one way we were flirting.
You were being very,
very friendly to him in a n I am not gay way,
but let's be honest,
we look like we could be a couple like broodish gay guy.
I mean there's a lot of those deals.
If you go to West Hollywood,
and I presume you don't when you're in town,
but if you go down Santa Monica Boulevard,
there's several clubs that have a lot of men that are built very similar to us.
They also might have beards,
like we do go hunting.
They know it's about gay sex,
so you know he could have gotten,
you know,
he'd be,
he was testing the waters.
The guy that's,
if you're gay,
you never know.
Look,
you've got to think if you're gay,
what is it?
They say it's like 10% of people are gay,
but I don't even think it's that.
I think that's wishful thinking.
I think it's probably like probably like one out of 20 let's say 5% whatever the
number is that people like.
I keep looking at Jamie,
I don't know why he's straight as fuck,
but whatever the number is,
you know,
how does a gay guy know whether another guy's gay?
You've got to ask him.
So if he says to you,
look at you muscles and you're like,
look at you,
Bam,
it's on.
You know,
you landed in Edmonton,
the g exchanged numbers.
Things get poppin.
How's the guy find out?
He doesn't find out unless he talks to you.
Right?
But there was nothing inappropriate the way he was communicating with you.
There was,
it was just fun.
There's was nothing inappropriate.
The way we were joking around about it,
I lightheartedly said,
if he doesn't smack you on the ass on the way out,
I'm going to be very disappointed.
We were just laughing and this woman read me the fucking riot act.
You'd be an arrogant.
Yeah.
She was saying I was arrogant and I go,
how was that arrogant?
I got my friends very good looking.
I look at him,
he's a handsome guy and she goes,
that flight attendant was very nice.
He was very friendly.
I go,
he was very nice.
I just think you're very arrogant.
I go,
how am I arrogant?
I just,
I don't understand that,
how that's arrogant,
but I think my friends good looking that up.
I'm a,
I'm upset that the guy didn't hit on them.
I don't understand.
You want the whole fucking flight,
the whole flight.
He's flirting with you the whole flight one way.
There's one way floating.
Thank you.
It was just the woman was upset that I made like that I was having fun.
She would want her to make an issue,
I think in front of her partner.
Exactly.
I guess,
yeah,
just it puts you in your place.
It backfired horribly.
It is.
I was mocking her.
I was smiling and mocking her.
I,
and I never got upset.
Like,
I never said fuck off,
dummy.
You know,
W which is we're getting close to fuck off,
dummy.
No,
cause she kept saying arrogant and I'm like,
look,
I'm probably the least homophobic person that looks like me.
You're ever gonna meet,
you know,
I'm just not,
I don't care.
I grew up,
I lived in San Francisco from the time I was seven to 11 my neighbors were gay
and that formative period of my life,
I just was around gay people all the time.
And then being in show business,
I know so many fucking gay people.
I have a lot of gay friends,
just gay comedians.
I don't know that dude.
But if I be friends with him just to find out about Scientology,
I really would.
So anyway,
where do,
how'd that,
how do we take that hard turn?
You're talking about arrogant buddy in the airport.
Oh yeah.
So this is a totally different time in the airport.
When you posted that picture up on Facebook and I got this fucking raw people
that were angry at me.
First of all,
you said,
I think you put up a clip the first time.
I was up there with Luke Bryan and I shot this bear.
Yes,
right.
A Hundred Job's filmed it and we had the Arrow coming out.
Amazing video.
We should show that line.
Yeah.
It's a crazy video,
man.
It's all how big fucking bear too.
So anyway,
this Arrow comes out,
you,
you retweeted it or did something to it.
Anyway,
you got hammered.
So you're like,
he goes,
hey Joe.
He's like,
you're swimming.
We go in this bear hunt.
He goes,
I don't want any pictures.
I don't want any video.
He,
I can't deal with this negative when you deal with it and this hate.
He goes,
that's all I've been dealing with for two or three days.
And so then we kind of rethought it.
Yeah.
I thought it.
And I was like,
wait a minute.
What?
What do I believe?
Yeah.
What do I believe in in my,
in my changing what I'm putting out there.
And a lot of people do do that.
You change what you put out there because you worried about the negative impact
of something that you actually believe in.
And I thought about it and I was like,
oh,
fuck that man.
I don't,
I don't not believe in hunting.
I don't not believe that you should be killing this bear and eating it.
There's nothing wrong with it,
so fuck it.
So you put the picture up and then woo.
The tidal wave of,
of hate just came my way.
So I wrote this blog entry.
I will eventually put up and I want to put it up to,
uh,
promote,
John and Jen too,
because I think they're,
they're just awesome folks and I'd love to pump up their business.
But,
um,
this guy came up to me at the fucking airport.
Fucking disgusting.
Meatheads oh,
that was actually the one that was on the blaze.
Yeah.
That was actually,
that was actually in support of me as I put up a whole series of tweets
explaining my position.
They had that on there.
Yeah.
That was very cool of them to do that.
And that had,
did you see that number there?
That had a 16 16,000 shares?
Yeah,
I mean,
that got to me,
that whole thing.
This whole thing gets the hunting message out,
you know,
the right type of hunting message out there.
Um,
and that's just what I'm trying to do it,
love it,
love it.
But anyway,
yeah,
I guide the airport,
comes up to me and he goes,
hey,
um,
I can't believe you killed a bear that's just so beyond fucked up.
And I just looked down and I go,
dude,
you're wearing leather shoes.
You wearing leather shoes.
And he goes,
a cow is not a bear.
I go,
yeah,
you're right.
When we were there,
a bear a a cub and then the mother came by and finish the cub off.
I told them that story then we talked about earlier.
Yeah,
I go sign.
Never heard of a cow doing that.
So yeah,
you're right.
Cows and bears are different.
The fuck he talked.
This hierarchy of animals that you're allowed to eat.
I'm not saying you should eat your neighbor's fucking dog.
Okay.
You know,
don't eat pets.
I love my cats.
I love my dogs.
I love animals.
It's not,
I'm not an animal hater,
but this idea that there's like an animal that is sacred,
you know,
like some magical Phoenix beast.
That's what I always hear.
That's what they're raised for.
Yeah.
That's so stupid that,
that argument is so stupid.
That's worse.
It's worse than an animal is imprisoned.
It's entire live.
Right.
It's only existence to be slaughtered,
to be slaughtered when you shoot a deer and that deer is wandering around eating
acorns and then boom,
or for you with,
you know,
the,
the Arrow hits him.
His life is over in seconds and his life was 100% wild until the moment it
ended.
Right.
That's a far better existence.
Far Better.
The moment my Arrow pass through that bear,
that bear was dead inside of 30 seconds.
We heard,
cause it's kind of creepy.
Um,
bears do a death moan,
um,
especially when you shoot them to the lungs,
right?
They do.
And so within 15 seconds we heard
[inaudible]
and you know,
John and user.
That's it.
You got it.
It was perfect.
And it was done within 30 seconds of that Arrow hitting it.
That animal's dead lived its entire life,
how many years it was alive and then one moment and it's dead and then we're
skinning it.
And then we ate it that night.
And the idea that someone can come up to you and be wearing leather shoes and in
some way judge you for killing and eating an animal and I'm having the hide
tanned.
I mean,
um,
or uh,
you know,
the skin is being treated so I'm going to have a rug made out of it.
I'm still eating the animal.
I feed it to my family.
I mean,
I'm taking advantage of every single aspect of this animal.
When you pass by a restaurant,
when you pass by a supermarket,
every road you drive down in America,
pretty much.
You'd go by a gas station and you see a fucking package of slim Jims.
Every animal that has been involved in making those products lived a life,
a horrifying existence that is unimaginable suffering in comparison to an animal
that you hunt.
Yeah.
Not,
not Turkey jerky though.
They're there.
That was paying the,
they lived a perfect life.
They don't even feel it when you tell him,
don't even know if it,
and then I guess on the polar opposite of that or I don't even know this whole
trying to figure out what the these people think.
I get people when you killed your bear,
and I had that up there,
people were posting messages on my Facebook saying they're going to kill my
daughter and put her head on the wall.
Whoa.
Is that how,
how do people get there?
Yeah,
they get there.
Well,
there's a lot of people involved in what's called the animal liberation movement
and it's so intense that there are folks that break into restaurants and steel
lobsters and let them loose back in the ocean.
You know,
God,
these mother fuckers don't understand that.
The reason why people are here today is because your ancestors ate animals.
If we were all just eating grass and fucking berries,
we would still be jumping out of trees because leopards are attacking us.
We literally wouldn't be here.
Right.
The human beings.
One of the main contributing factor to the growth and development of the human
brain was the fact that we changed our diet from plant based diet to a meat
based diet.
So the human intestines changed our whole digestive process change and it freed
up resources that allow the brain to grow and develop.
This is like accepted scientific fact.
Obviously I'm a fucking idiot.
So when I'm telling you this,
it's not based on anything.
I truly understand them basically repeating things that smart people figured
out,
but that is what they figured out.
I mean,
that's a main scientific point when it comes to the development of the human
brain.
So that's why we're here,
dummy.
You know,
we're not here for Tofu.
All right?
And by the way,
they've also been proved,
been proven over the last decade or so,
that plants have much more understanding of their environment than we ever gave
them credit for.
And just because they don't have the ability to communicate with us.
They don't scream when you pull them out of the ground or they don't try to get
away.
When you go.
Reaching for a turnip doesn't mean that they're not a life form that reacts to
its environment.
The same way in animal does.
When an animal,
you know,
turns its ears up and looks around because it it,
it thinks a predator,
it's coming.
That's a natural reaction.
Plants have natural reactions to plants develop toxins in order to discourage
predation.
They,
they have literally things that they develop over time to keep things from
eating them.
They didn't want to be fucking Eaton.
Okay.
When you're eating cauliflower,
I have to feel sorry for plants.
Now you have to feel sorry for plants.
You know,
clients can scream.
No one w why people couldn't be so self righteous.
It's true.
It's a really foolish notion that life eats life.
It's always eaten life.
That's what happens.
That's how humans get by.
That's how plants get buy.
Everything eats some form of life has to,
there's a cycle and we somehow or another want to disconnect ourselves from that
or disconnect ourselves from the,
the concept of things that are sentient,
things that are aware of their environment,
that things that can see in here.
They're similar to us,
but it,
you know,
not everybody wants to be disconnected because after the last podcast I was on
with you,
do you know how many new
bow hunters wanted to listen to what we talked about?
Listen to the connection we talked about and never had thought about bow
hunting,
never had shot a bow and all of a sudden they were at their pro shop or they
want to learn more.
I mean,
I've had guys who said,
I just as I think it was yesterday,
this Guy Siemens Meshes,
he goes,
I hadn't heard of you before Joe's podcast.
He goes,
that I sat one night and watched every one of your videos.
Wow.
I mean,
so that's awesome.
So there's,
there's people,
there are people who are disconnected,
but there are people who I guess had been inspired by talking about this and
talking about,
you know,
the type of hunting and the connection we have and want that same thing,
and want to have something to train for and want to have a purpose.
You know,
like you said,
um,
why are you in shape?
You know,
are you competing?
Are You well,
are my purpose is to be the ultimate Predator would be the very best at what I
do.
And other people are interested in that too.
And finding out what that's about.
Yeah.
And I think that this disconnection that people have in society is a main cause
of people just feeling like shit all the time.
They don't feel rewarded by life when your day to day existence is just doing
something that you don't enjoy and then coming home and resting,
getting ready to do it again.
It sucks when you have something that you enjoy,
whether it's bow hunting or any sort of hobby,
any,
any sort of existence and any sort of a um,
uh,
discipline or practice,
you work towards something and you get a reward for that work,
right?
Feels good,
sacrifice,
reward.
And then there's the nother notch that is above that is this sacrifice worked
for something,
achieve the results,
and you actually live off those results.
You're eating it.
And that's,
that's a very primal thing mannerful but it doesn't mean we're less evolved.
This is what people have to get into their mind lit,
release all your preconceived notions of what a hunter is.
These rednecks just out,
they're torturing animals.
You psychopaths release all those preconceived notions and take in the concept
of wild of what wild is.
Just it,
just to be out in nature and watch all these things run around.
Watch animals chase after each other.
Watch.
Watch this natural process that gives zero fucks if you're there or not there
and then realize that this can be your source of sustenance.
This,
you can live in that world for brief moments in time.
Train for it,
prepare for it,
bring back that protein and live and live a healthier life too.
Yeah.
That I think that if that fact right there will you just explain affects every
minute of my life every day.
I mean,
because that's basically I'm known as a bow hunter,
the bow hunter,
whoever this guy who does whatever.
So that's,
that's had such a powerful on me,
thus all,
I mean,
it's not all I am,
but it's a big part of what I am.
And that's,
that's what I always say.
I always say,
well,
Bowen,
he's changed my life and I see these people who,
who messaged me and,
uh,
because of your podcast and they want that same,
could impact my life that same way could give my life that type of meaning.
And uh,
uh,
I do want to address one thing people talk about,
you know,
hunters being rednecks are barbarians or heartless or this or that.
Um,
you know,
my buddy,
uh,
Rick Carone is battling cancer right now.
And when I do,
when I was going to sell something like I've sold bows,
highest bidder type thing,
hunters are the most generous,
heartfelt people.
I mean,
that's basically all my followers are hunters and they are so giving and so
caring and loving of somebody they've never met.
They've just learned about maybe,
you know,
from my website or,
or from whatever else.
And I dunno,
I just,
I have a hard,
I mean it's just amazing to me just the heart hunters have.
And if people are so far,
so wrong on,
I guess wouldn't what moves us,
what's important to us because I see people giving thousands of dollars to help
somebody they've never met.
Well,
uh,
the,
the amount of negativity that you get from nonhunters in comparison to the
amount of negativity and hate you get from hunters,
it's hugely disproportionate.
What you talked about,
about being respectful about how when you say you disagree with someone on
Twitter,
you don't say fuck off you fucking dummy and you don't get involved in any of
these,
these negative exchanges because of that you attract this very positive
following.
And I've been to your Facebook page and I've read the comments when you,
when you put something up on Instagram and it's an incredibly positive group of
people.
Yeah.
Credits,
incredibly positive.
And also people that recognize the rewards of this lifestyle and recognize the
negative impact or the negative opinion that a lot of people don't understand it
have.
And so they feel connected with each other in sort of solidarity against what
they perceive to be these ignorant people that judge them.
Yeah.
Right now it's uh,
I know and that's the thing.
So I do get negative every once in a while and all I do,
I block them and delete it just because I don't want that one person skewing one
person can skew the whole
comment train basically.
And then just,
it takes away from the whole point,
right.
Maybe I'm living or created this fantasy land of positivity by doing that.
But that's fine because it,
it helps me,
I see other people at impacts.
And I guess the closest thing to negativity that I've,
I've done lately is just this,
this slogan I have on my new shirt and it's nobody cares.
Work harder.
Yeah.
And that's,
I always say,
because everything else is all positive.
The nobody cares.
It's tough love.
It's a little bit of tough love.
It's like everybody has issues,
everybody has hurdles,
everybody has challenges.
But at the end of the day,
they'll listen to you.
They don't really care that much.
If you don't have what you want,
you need to work harder.
So that's,
that's all I've done.
I'm,
I'm not looking for sympathy on anything and,
and,
uh,
I just,
you know,
I just hope other people take that from this,
I still love you and care about you guys.
We just need to work harder if we don't have what we want.
Well that's you dude.
You're,
you're that guy.
Every time we were in a,
in camp,
you were out there running,
you went,
you went running basically every day fucking Alberta.
You,
you put in the work man.
And that's why you become successful.
What you do.
I like people that work hard and push through things because it inspires me to
do the same thing.
So even that shirt would,
might be conceived as Nang or perceived as negative.
I don't think it's negative.
It's,
it's inspirational.
It's like people need to hear that shit.
Just get your fucking ass out of it.
People love to find an excuse.
Oh my fucking hangnails really bugging me,
man.
I can't lift.
Just,
just do,
just get out and do something.
And that's why that just do it.
Campaign was so powerful for Nike,
you know,
because just do it is really what you need to hear sometimes.
Just shut the fuck up and go to work.
Get it done.
I read the rocks tweets in his Instagrams.
Oh yeah,
because that guy will fly into somewhere at,
you know,
four o'clock in the morning and he's at the gym at five and he takes pictures
and,
and he's fucking killing it every day.
His Dad.
Yeah.
And that's why he looks that way.
You see him in that movie Hercules.
I haven't seen it.
You don't get that way by taking the day off cause you have a hangnail you get
that.
You get to look like that pause where because of some artificial and supplements
and I'll find him.
I had been frozen sort room but there's also a lot of hard work involved.
No doubt a fucking bout it.
You could take all the steroids in the world.
Your body doesn't grow like that.
It grows like that from hard work period.
In a local storage and hard work is a magical ingredient if you can.
If you could apply that magical ingredient to almost everything in life and hard
work also comes with hard thinking,
hard work.
Everybody likes to think of as being like,
oh you just grunt and put in the effort.
No hard work is also preparation,
thought process.
Understanding,
and that is a big part of hunting as well.
It's not just about,
you know,
oh,
it's really hard to get up that hill.
Get to that set fest,
7,000 feet elevation where those elk are.
No,
you got to understand the,
when you got to understand the behavior of these animals,
you got to understand what's,
what's going on in the Rut.
What is this?
What does this bull elk attracted to?
Are you going to attract a bull by pertaining to be a cow which she wants to
have sex with?
Or are you going to be a bull,
which we want.
He wants to challenge and you got to know what to do,
what and what to do.
When I,
I'm amazed at how much knowledge is involved in hunting and how much like
Steve Rinella is of a goddamn encyclopedia.
I need to get you two together.
I want to do is a lot smarter than me.
Uh,
well,
he's a very educated man.
I mostly just a bow hunter.
You guys would get along great though.
Well we need to do is,
uh,
when we go next year,
when we go,
I'm a bow hunting for elk.
Yeah.
We should do it for his show.
It might be a few extra people though.
It might be a pain in the ass.
I know you liked her.
It will solo.
It would be a huge pain in the ass,
but it might be worth it to get you two together.
It'd be really interesting.
I think you guys get along great,
but that he's really opened my eyes to how much information is involved in
hunting.
I mean how much knowledge,
how much,
how much you have to know.
Especially,
you know,
he's doing it all year round,
so he's constantly aware of the cycles,
the breeding,
mating,
food patterns,
all the different things that you have to pay attention to about each individual
animal.
This is just a lot going on there,
man.
It's a rich,
intense world.
Yeah,
no,
it's so,
it's so far removed from,
you know,
the,
like we probably addressed it the last time,
but the,
the bubba hunting stereotype of driving around drinking beers,
shooting from the truck
that's still out there.
Right.
But that's out there with everything.
I mean,
I get that with the UFC,
you know,
people are like,
oh,
you're a UFC great.
What are you doing man?
You fucking hanging around with a bunch of assholes,
beating the shit out of each other.
Look,
come to Jujitsu class with me.
You'll meet some of the nicest,
friendliest people in.
A lot of them are nerds.
Okay?
A lot of my friends were Jujitsu.
If you looked at them,
you would say,
oh,
that guy's like a nerd.
He's like a nerdy guy,
Magen nerd.
We'll fucking strangle you with his legs.
You know,
like,
it's,
what it is,
is people that really get into something that is ultimately very rewarding.
And I think it's ultimately very rewarding to accomplish something that's
difficult to do.
And it's something that's missing from a lot of people's lives.
A lot of people are doing something that's easy to do and they're looking to
take coffee breaks and they're looking to take a nice long lunch break and they
were going to take a newspaper and the John when they take a shit,
cause nobody can say anything.
Hey I got to go to the bathroom,
man,
what do you want?
And there's a lot of people that I look to use paper files,
they have to write a fucking run out of batteries on the toilet and we read his
paper.
That's true.
Some people do,
man.
Brian counts still reads the newspaper every time I'm with them,
motherfuckers got the New York Times.
Especially if someone's looking,
I like having a paper breakfast.
I'll say that.
Hey,
so this is one thing I forgot to ask last time,
but,
so my kids are big,
typical regular sports fans like NFL.
Of course I like Alec Ufc.
So they're like dad,
do you think a UFC fighter?
It's like say somebody like a Chad Mendez.
Who's fighting Joseph Aldo tomorrow night.
Tomorrow for the title.
Love Chad.
He's a,
he's a hundred by the way.
This year.
I know,
I know he's a stud,
but uh,
so say Patrick Willis,
who's this huge 240 pound linebacker who would win in a fight?
Chad?
200%.
100%
and so that's hard to explain because what,
what people are my kids anyway.
See is this huge jacked,
you know,
giant guy,
NFL and then Chad,
who's what,
what is,
he won 55 he walks around probably one 60 fights at one 45.
Okay,
so why,
why would he beat him?
Well,
he def,
he did definitely doesn't have to win.
Like it is possible that the NFL guy could pick them up and smash them.
Just drop them on a rock or something like that.
Cause you're dealing with a hundred extra pounds.
Alpha male testosterone and bone and,
and aggression and Mexican supplements.
But is that him right there?
That's the guy.
Why am I looking at his dick,
bro?
What the fuck?
Kind of gay porn shit.
That's the first one that comes up.
Tell that due to pull his pants up.
I don't need to see those fuck muscles at the top of your head.
He listened to me.
Boys,
if you're trying to attract the gals,
I understand it,
but when you're around other men,
pull up,
pull your pants up so I don't see your fuck muscles,
those weird upper hip muscles.
You know what I mean?
There's gotta be sexy.
The v part,
this shit.
Yeah.
These things right in there and you can see it and see it up there.
No,
I'm not going to show you,
but I'm just standing up.
So look at that is I'm seeing way too much dick.
Anyway,
that's,
that's Patrick was his only hope is,
well there's two parts.
If he has martial arts training chats fucked.
You mean if he doesn't,
if he's like a brown belt in Jujitsu,
he knows how to kickbox chats.
Fuck.
Cause he's just too big.
But if he's just a regular dude with no martial arts training at all,
jazz going to get us back.
He'll just,
he'll have to choke him out.
He's not going to,
not might knock 'em out.
Chat hits pretty fucking hard,
but he's going to have to hit him.
Perfect.
You're dealing with a much larger skulled and Chad's right.
You know,
when you're dealing with Chad's size hands compared to his hands,
which probably our biggest,
my fucking laptop.
Right size is very important though.
The idea that size doesn't mean anything that's ridiculous.
Size means a lot.
It just doesn't mean as much as technique.
Technique means the most,
but there's a lot of factors involved in like who would win in a fight.
The most important factor is knowledge and technique.
There was a dude I used to roll with a 10 plan.
It was a really nice guy who's a former football player.
He was 250 pounds and whenever I used to roll with them,
I just call it riding the bull.
[inaudible]
got to go ride the bull.
Cause every time I get on top of him,
well,
when anytime we'd scramble,
I would have to initially let him get on top because he's just too God damn big
for me to take them down.
So I'd let him get on top and then I'd have to sweep him and then I'd eventually
ride them and then eventually catch them.
Right.
It would take me a while.
I have to wear his big ass out.
Right.
But I was just better than him.
I'd been doing Jujitsu for 15 years and he'd only been doing Jujitsu for like
six months.
So it was just a matter of riding the bull.
I would just hang on,
knew him,
but God damn,
he was fucking strong as shit.
And I always think if this motherfucker knew half of what I knew I'd be doing
that just be,
there's a huge advantage of being bigger and stronger.
It's just not as much of an
excuse me.
Not as much as an advantage as being a technical and understanding what's going
on in,
in,
inside of fight.
One thing I was going to ask too about,
you know,
I get a lot of questions on diet and,
and putting on muscle and this and that.
How many,
I think we've,
you said eating meat has evolved the brain basically.
But,
uh,
I think eating meat is how I've been able to retain muscle and still run as much
as I do.
Just all the protein I take.
So I was wondering how of fighters,
how many of those guys are Vegan or vegetarian?
There's no elite fighters that are vegan except for Jake shields who is a Vegan.
Um,
but he still eats eggs I think.
because uh,
and he would eat game.
He said he would eat like a,
I'm an animal that's hunted,
but he just doesn't believe in factory farming.
It does it purely for ethical reasons.
But Jake,
although Jake is fairly elite,
he was cut from the UFC.
Now he's fighting in a smaller organization cause he couldn't beat the best of
the best guys.
You know,
it just lost recently in Hector Lombard,
who knows how much better Jake would be if he existed in us.
Uh,
a diet of black bear and elk.
I mean,
I don't know,
man.
I don't really a lot better.
Who knows?
If you want to make the UFC,
you better eat meat.
I don't know.
Jake is really fucking good,
really,
really good grappler.
Um,
but he's also just tough as nails.
I think that every edge counts.
There was a reason why people take vitamin supplements.
There's a reason why people take protein supplements,
amino acids,
all the things that are legal that people take.
They take it because it gives you an edge.
It might be a small edge,
but that small edge could be the difference between escaping a submission and
tapping out.
It could be the difference between synching up a submission and and the guy gets
away.
It could be the difference between getting that final push to make a take down
and not and it's those small edges all add up.
Massage therapy,
a yoga,
every little edge.
Meditation,
isolation tanks was like guys are doing everything to get every little edge and
the idea that you would do all these different things but you wouldn't eat meat.
Man,
it's the science is all there.
This idea that Vegan athletes are superior is fucking preposterous.
It's so difficult to get B12.
It's so difficult to get all of the amino acids.
It's so difficult to get a full,
complete balanced protein without eating meat cause that's really fucking hard
now.
And so and that that brings me back to bow hunting.
You talk about all those little edges added up to give Earl,
those little things add up to give you an edge.
That's,
that's bow hunting,
bow hunting.
Because people will say,
well,
you don't need to do this.
You don't need to do that.
That's overkill.
That's too much to me.
I'm thinking I'm just adding one more little positive edge to my arsenal and
then that's how,
you know,
killed
13 bowls in the last five years.
You know,
they all haven't been just perfect.
I've needed little edges to make it happen.
And so that to me,
fighting is a lot like something as difficult as bow hunting.
I think there's a lot of ego involved.
You know,
there's a lot of people that don't,
they don't want to think that they're not putting in as much work as you.
So they're like,
you know,
all these guys meathead.
Yeah,
you don't need to pull that much weight,
but what's that much weight to you and what's that much weight?
To me,
you know,
my question is,
okay,
how much weight do you lift when you let go to the gym?
If you can only like do a curl with like 25 pounds and I can do it with a
hundred how much stronger am I then you and what is the difference between a 50
pound bow to you and an 80 pound boat?
To me exactly.
I fucked my shoulder up by pulling a 90 pound bow a hundred times a day.
150 times.
It's not bad.
It's a,
I actually,
I'm just finishing this Regina king treatment.
It's the attendance,
attendance were strained.
You're given all this repetitive ammunition now for why you shouldn't shoot a
heavy bow e well,
you know what,
if I worried about injuries,
I would have never done anything.
Right.
And then I've had three knee surgeries.
I had my nose fixed.
I'm,
I'm uh,
I've,
I'm full of fucking surgeries.
That's what guys say to me.
Cause you know,
I run basically I do the same thing every single day,
my training and they say,
you know,
what are you going to do?
And 40 years when he's still on a hunt,
but you won't be able to hunt because you've been running every day and wearing
out your joints.
I'm like,
I don't know if I'm going to be alive tomorrow,
let alone 40 years from now,
I'm going to worry about tomorrow,
tomorrow and today I'm going to get my best.
Well,
people are always looking for some negative man.
They're always looking for something and they could point at you that makes you
less than them or makes you less than you think you are.
People look to diminish.
Look,
I look to diminish.
I'm a fucking comedian.
That's what I do.
I point holes a thing and I look at Shit.
I go to this stupid bitch had done to do that right now my thing,
but that is what I do,
so I understand the mindset,
but it's a very disempowering mindset to instead not be inspired to,
to,
to not be inspired to just poke holes in things like you.
You don't need 80 pounds.
How bunch is just be inspired to go.
How about you doing a little bit of exercise?
How can you not worry about a guy who was obviously far physically stronger than
you,
who only pulls an extra 20 pounds of weight.
It's really not that big of a God damn deal.
Right.
But yeah,
it's,
it's an ego thing.
I think in a lot of guys that,
that the crabs in a bucket was a good one of our most popular stories from the
last time.
Yeah.
But uh,
yeah,
so there's that still I guess always going to be out there.
It is.
It's always going to be out there.
I'm fascinated by the technology involved in bow hunting too.
Um,
I mean I,
in the back here we have a,
one of those uh,
radar things we shoot an Arrow through the chronograph tells you the exact speed
of the Arrow.
And that was another thing that like I had to learn that I thought was really
interesting.
The spine of the hour,
how stiff the Arrow
is.
Well,
how many grains the are ways in relationship to the bow in relationship to the
speed of the Arrow.
Then you have to calculate all that and put out a site tape.
And that that's how you figure out with the guys at the bow rack.
D made it me a sight tape for the carbon spider and it's fucking amazing.
It's so dead on because mine was all goofy.
The last one that I printed out myself,
it's like a lot involved
and we're basically has run scientist.
No,
no that's,
we do have to give a plug to the bowl rack.
Yeah,
we have Springfield,
Oregon,
Springfield,
Oregon.
We have such an advantage having Bose set up by professionals,
guys who do it every single day.
There's a lot of guys in small towns south throughout everywhere that they can
buy the same bow by the same arrows,
by the same everything.
The bow is not set up correctly.
It's not tuned and it's just not going to perform.
So we know when we go out,
especially cause I'm at the bowl rag,
I paper to my Bose,
we put it into Hooters shooter,
which is a machine that shoots your bow for you to,
to to tell you whether the boat's set up correctly or there's some human error
involved.
So basically at the end of the day when we go hunting,
we know the bow is at the top,
the top of its capability and any error is us.
So then if I can control my errors,
arrows going to go right where it's supposed to go.
And um,
that's also been using,
you know,
Hoyt bows.
Yeah.
Best bows out there as far as I'm concerned.
And you're right,
that technology is just fascinating.
Yeah.
These Hoyt balls are just incredible man.
The carbon fiber spider turbo that we used when we were in a candida,
you're talking about a bear,
I mean 250 plus pound animal.
This arrow went straight through its body and went so deep into a log that I had
to break it off because I couldn't get the broad head out right.
And that that Arrow is sitting up on the wall in my office.
I mean,
it pass clean through this animal like that,
like butter.
And this is a giant difference between that and what you think of as a bow and
Arrow that like from the boy scout days,
you know when you would shoot those little,
those little Shitty recurve bows like 20 pound poll or whatever it was,
they just don't have the kind of impact that these boats have with the cams and
the technology and the way they engineer these risers.
I mean these things are incredible pieces of work and engineering.
Well,
and I w let's see,
what did I just get?
I just got the brand new night drum and actually I brought it at sitting over
there.
And you,
you just asked when I walked in and you're like,
why did you bring your bow?
I'm like,
cause I take my bowl everywhere.
Why wouldn't I bring it?
I need to keep that thing in my sight.
So uh,
yeah,
bring that when you go on the road and you,
you set up targets,
places meet like here people say,
no,
I'm going to be in la.
So they want to shoot and where are you going to shoot today?
Are going to shoot somewhere today?
Yeah,
yeah.
Now they're going to go,
there's guys will,
uh,
there's three people here who have places that they shoot.
So I don't know if it's a range or if it's their,
but
they've all invited me to meet up.
I'm going to meet up with at least one of them.
Maybe they'll all be there and we're going to shoot bows and one of them is
going to be,
that flight attendant is going to be waiting for you.
He's going to be wearing velcro underwear,
uh,
Japanese,
he probably is from here.
Chances are he is from California.
Everyone's gay in California.
And so he trying to say,
how dare you.
How dare you.
That's cool though,
that you have this sort of connection with a,
with fans.
I know you do a lot of those,
uh,
Cabela's openings or bass pro shops,
whatever it is.
Which one is it?
Both.
Both of them.
You do both of them do appearances at both.
And when I go,
I just,
like I said,
I liked the,
the positive atmosphere,
like the comradery.
I like to see people working.
So I'll say,
hey,
I went to Alaska.
You know,
and I've said,
I'm going to,
I did the bass pro shop grand opening and in Anchorage and I said,
let's go run some mountains up there.
So I met up with a couple of guys,
did two different runs and uh,
we hammered out some tough mountain runs and it just was soaking wet,
freezing and never felt more alive.
That's so awesome.
That's cool too that you connect with people like that because that's also what
I saw him when we were in camp in Alberta.
All of those guys had come into that camp that we,
cause they knew that you were going to be there.
They wanted to hunt during that week.
And what a positive group of people.
How best you guys guys.
I never met any of them before.
Yeah,
it was,
they hadn't met each other before.
That was what was crazy when we got there,
we,
it was almost like they were all old buddies that were hanging out together.
And then slowly I started piecing together.
I'm like,
when did you guys meet yesterday?
You guys don't even fucking know each other.
Like,
this is like this grand party of like really friendly guys.
I thought it was just a bunch of old high school buddies got together,
but no,
just super positive,
super friendly and we had a great time.
Yeah,
no,
I mean I,
I,
I would,
I don't know what type of group of people you could bring together that,
that in that short of time and have that type of connection.
I don't know.
Hunting just seems to do that to people.
I mean,
I don't know about you,
but when I'm somewhere I don't care where here,
uh,
were whatever town I'm in.
When I see somebody in Cammo,
I'm like looking at him wondering if you know,
hey,
do you want to talk about hunting?
You Hunt w why are you wearing Camo?
But it's just like that brotherhood.
It's,
it's weird.
I had a Hoyt hat on and I was at the airport and this old dude sat next to me
and it just plopped down right next to me and he goes,
how long you've been bow hunting?
It's the old dude from Texas.
He had a Lonestar belt buckle on and he started just telling me stories about
hunting for elk and hunting for this and that and bow hunting.
He does all kinds of hunting,
but he does a lot of bow hunters too.
And just that was the green light.
He just plopped down next to me and just started talking and we had like a half
an hour conversation.
Well,
and nowadays,
you know that old school dude.
That's awesome.
Nowadays the young guys are the guys that seem,
I don't,
I can't,
I'm in communication with,
they're so passionate about new bows and technology.
Like you mentioned like the unveiling of a new bow.
Like,
so if you have a Hoyt that people are like,
what year is it?
It's like right us 2014 oh yeah,
you don't,
so you don't have a 2015 nitrogen turbo yet.
Huh?
And this is like,
it's crazy.
These and so Hoyt and you know all these other companies,
biotech,
they have this,
you know it's going to come out on the 15th and they'll give teasers and people
are just on all these forums.
Trying to guess what's,
what's going to be different with the new technology is going to be and it's,
it's just so fun and so people are so passionate about it.
It's a,
I don't know,
it's like the release of a new iPhone.
Oh totally.
It's really similar.
It's real assemble and you find out,
oh look at this,
I got this new anti torquing technology.
What is the new anti torquing technology?
What does that all about?
That's a,
on the cable roller,
it's supposed to.
How that set up is it's going to help you tune your bow because there is no
torque in that one.
Normally when you,
when you pull your string back and your cable,
there's a lot of tension,
a lot of torque right there.
Typically back in the old school days,
I would just kind of slide on a bar.
And now Hoyt has come up with this system,
the anti torquing technology where there's no torque on that and,
and how they've designed the riser is,
is like,
it's just helps all the tuning issues,
the performance of the bow,
that's the antique torquing is one part of it.
The riser design is another part of it.
All the little tweaks they make,
it's just making a s m suite or smoother shooting bow that tunes up quicker.
And what that does is you talked about your bear,
how that Arrow flew straight blew right through there for that to happen,
excuse me,
is uh,
that Arrow has to be just flying perfect.
And all that plays into that and that's,
that's how you get those clean,
quick kills.
And if you're shooting targets,
that's how you get every Arrow in the X.
And so it's all those little things like people will say,
actually,
I shot the bow and uh,
you know,
speed wise it was a little bit slower than the carbon spider turbo is three feet
per second.
Slower.
But you look at the,
the brace height,
which is a big part of why a bow is fast and why it's not the British side is
the distance between the string and the rifle,
the riser Izer,
right?
So the taller that is the,
the quicker that the Arrow is off the string.
So that means as you as a shooter have less impact on it being imperfect.
The shorter it is,
it's going to be on that string longer,
longer,
longer.
And then it finally comes off right when it gets close to your hand and that
riser there.
And so because it's propelled for longer,
it's going to be faster,
but you also have more time to drop your bow arm or,
or do or flinch or do whatever risk,
torque or that.
And so it's generally a less accurate arrow.
So my,
my new bow is a little slower,
but it's got a taller brace height.
So meaning it's more forgiving.
Three feet is pretty nominal.
Not that big a deal,
but it's so sweet shooting.
I mean,
I went down there and tuning a bow,
used to be this whole elongated process and it would take sometimes days to get
that thing shooting through paper.
Right.
And get the Arrow fly.
And Ryan is like,
is the Arrow under spine,
am I,
am I talking my wrist is having my thumb behind my neck affecting all the stuff
now I go down there,
it was like two shots.
Perfect.
And you knew it was ready.
Well you're an expert archer.
So I,
one of the things I've learned from watching your videos is I've seen your old
spider turbo and then you went from that to the carbon spider tour.
When she see the difference in the amount of feet per second,
how smooth it feels dead.
And you could see in your own videos the progression of the technology,
which is really kind of
cool.
Yeah.
Uh,
what I've noticed,
you know,
even those old bows,
those,
those would kill those would probably get the job done probably 90% of the time.
But it's that,
those little things I said that 10% that's going to make a difference,
you know,
is,
is it going to be a lethal shot or is going to be just a wound,
a flesh wound?
And so those little things.
So yeah,
before I've killed for 26 years and the Bose that I started with are night and
day different than the Bose now,
but still,
it's a primitive sport still.
It's very difficult still.
There's a lot of human
influence on that Arrow and whether it's going to fly,
we're supposed to so you can still mess it up.
One thing that I've noticed that I've,
that's helped me more than anything is that long distance shooting.
I shoot out a hundred yards all the time and we shot long distance up in Alberta
actually.
Um,
the guys want to do that because that's sort of what I'm known for.
And what that does is I'm not going to be out there should,
you didn't animals at 140 yards or anything like that.
But man at that slam dunk range of what I would consider slam dunk 30 40 yards,
I'm going to able to make that shot because technique wise,
I know I'm dialed in,
I know my my whole week shooting money because it's tuned perfectly.
And so that's what's happened.
I mean I killed,
you know,
those bowls this year,
one Arrow,
they were down in seconds.
Those are big 800 pound animals and it's just perfect.
And that's,
you know,
that's what it's all about.
And the discipline involved is so fascinating because it seems like such a
straightforward thing.
Your arms out straight,
you pull the string back,
aim through sight and he let the Arrow go.
But meanwhile we're in camp,
there's fucking 10 dudes in camp,
all of them bow hunters.
You are consistently outperforming all of us consistently nail and bulls eyes
over and over again.
And everybody's perplexed and puzzle how that,
what the fuck am I doing wrong?
Like what's the deer and the differences just inches,
inches here,
left,
right.
But it's just the amount of time you put in and the focus and the discipline and
just,
just the,
the knowledge that you've accumulated after all these years.
And that's one of the things that's so attractive about it is that it's not
something that's easy.
I thought you're going to be attractive about me.
And I was like,
go right back to,
it's the fact that it's not easy is exciting.
You know,
the fact that man,
when you shoot a bullseye at 40 yards and it just sits right in there is so
satisfying.
Oh,
it feels so good.
Yeah,
it's weird.
It's like you would think like,
I've watched videos online now of archery competitions.
Yeah.
But guys are just shooting at a piece of paper 40 yards away.
And when it goes in that bull's eye,
everybody cheers and it's this something really satisfying about it.
Dude,
you watch.
So on my youtube channel,
I don't know,
there's almost 3 million views on there,
which isn't that big a deal.
If I,
for Katy Perry for a bow hunting,
it's quite a few years.
But,
so I have a hundred and I don't know,
maybe 50 videos.
So if you go on there and you say most viewed out of all those videos and I've
got some cool stuff on there.
I had got bears,
dine,
water,
buffalo dying and l dying and you know it's a sheep are on cliffs,
the most viewed or all shooting a bow.
Just targets standing there shooting a bow.
Cause people who who bow hunt or even just people who do archery,
they want to see someone who's better at it than them doing it.
So they could go,
okay,
what's he doing here?
And going on maybe.
So yeah,
it's very,
I lie,
enjoy watching you shoot it.
And this is ridiculous.
I have my own fucking bow,
but I like watching you do it cause I'm old.
What's he doing right here?
Yeah,
it's different.
Well and I get a lot,
I had to turn the comments off a lot of a lot of the videos because so many
stupid comments that drove me crazy.
So I'm like,
I'll turn this,
turn off the comments.
But on the comments that I've left on with the equipment,
it's people just,
they watch everything I do and they're like,
what side is that?
What rest is that?
Why is he moving his hand like that?
Well,
I mean it's just like you said,
studying and studying and studying and that's,
it's just,
to me it's just awesome that people care that much.
Yeah.
And this is like,
we go back to this is what archery can do.
It can impact people,
give them something to think about and not obsess about weird negative stuff.
It's,
they're thinking in their minds working about bow hunting and archery and how
they can be better.
And that's,
I like that.
And again,
there is some sort of a zen meditative aspect to just shooting a bow into a
target.
And I recommended really highly to people that have zero desire to hunt,
just fine an archery range.
And if you can take a lesson,
take a lesson,
you know,
and get a bow figuring out how to set it up.
Maybe you know,
if there's a pro shop near you that's really good.
Someone
can help you,
man.
Just a fun,
fun way to spend time.
I,
my kids do it,
man.
I got a six year old.
A four year old is shoot bows and arrows.
Yeah.
Oh,
kids love my daughter.
we'll go out there and here's the,
here's what's funny about shooting far.
You know like the popular ones like me shooting 140 or I think I shot a balloon
at like 227 yards or something like that.
But we,
I take my daughter out there,
she's 10 she's got this little white recurve and so she's shooting,
we had this shooting a 20 yards is a big bag and she's like,
dad,
how far is that bear?
I'm like,
I dunno.
It's like 70 yards.
She's like,
could I shoot at it?
I mean she was to shoot far too,
right?
Yeah.
She just,
you just want to know if you can hit it right and that's just,
she's not thinking about hunting or doing anything.
She's thinking about,
she wants to see if that Arrow will hit that where she wants it to.
Well,
people who shoot a free throw want to know if they could shoot a three pointer.
Yeah.
You know,
you want to know,
you want to back up a little.
All right,
let's try it.
Color.
Can you hit it back here?
You know,
that's what people are all about.
I mean,
that's part of what's wrong with us.
We constantly,
constantly pushed the boundaries.
More.
More is better.
Yeah.
What are you thoughts on crossbows?
What do you think about crossing?
Well,
um,
to me,
I mean I've never even shot across bow,
but what I know about them is you don't need to practice at all basically once
you get,
once it's cited in,
it's like a rifle.
I don't like crossbows during bow season.
Uh,
I don't,
if people want to use a crossbow,
that's fine.
I have nothing against crossbows.
I don't think they should be allowed in bow season because it's different.
We talked about the discipline and the commitment and,
and everything.
You need to be proficient with a bow.
You don't need,
you don't need that with a crossbow
walking dead's got everybody crossbow happy.
Yeah.
That dude on the walking dead fucks everything up.
But that crossbow
due to Darrell Darrell,
imagine what he'd do with a mean kid shoots at crossbones.
It goes six inches in some rotten zombie.
Right.
I'll play,
you would go through 10 rotten zombies.
Well,
do they have a lighter arrow?
Is that what it is?
Yeah.
Yeah,
because it's,
it's shorter,
but the Arrow,
the shaft is similar but it's half the length or I don't know what it is,
but it's,
and that's lighter,
so it's not carrying that energy,
that momentum.
So they have a problem with like pass throughs and stuff like that with a like
passing through an animal.
Is it more difficult with a crossbow because it's a lighter,
well,
the lighter towel.
Yeah.
I mean you get,
okay,
the whole thing with an Arrow,
the light or the Arrow,
the less kinetic energy you're going to have.
So,
and people will talk about,
well that's not momentum,
Dah,
Dah.
But usually a kinetic energy or Arrow possesses the more penetration it's going
to get,
um,
to increase kinetic energy.
All you do is add weight.
So your boat could be slower.
But if the arrows more kinetic energy,
so it's a heavier arrow going slower,
but there's more behind it.
Right.
So it's almost more important to have weight than it is to have,
but there's a point of diminishing returns,
right?
Yeah.
That's way up at like 800 and some grains.
Oh really?
Which is a very,
I've never even shot an arrow that heavy that what I used for,
uh,
what the water buffalo in Australia was a 650 grand in Arrow and that's heavy.
You know what we use for bears for 50.
So the diminishing return point is over 800 grains and it 450 grains still
shooting 288 feet a second.
Yeah.
Which is for folks who don't know what that looks like,
you don't even barely see the arrow.
Yeah.
So for make energy,
that's probably,
I think,
I know I did it.
It's like 80 some foot pounds,
kinetic energy with,
and that doesn't mean anything to anybody other than it hits hard.
Shit's lethal.
It's very lethal.
Especially you put them on tech,
you know the heads we use were Mantech broadheads razor sharp heads.
Yeah.
It's going to,
it's going to blow through there.
And like,
like I said,
we went through the animal and then so deep into a log that I couldn't get it
out.
I had a break off the tip.
You know what was shooting a bow like we talked about,
just the fascination behind it is when I was in Tanzania,
those guys,
you know,
the natives they had had,
who knows what type of Bose they've seen.
So we're setting up Elian Bait there and had a like half a buffalo hanging and
I'd put a little yellow leaf there and I'd get back 40 yards.
Uh,
I want to see,
you know,
if,
if a lion was here,
where would my arrow hit?
So they'd be standing there.
I'd be standing back.
We'd have the bait there at the leaf on it.
And I had Stan and everybody ready.
Yeah.
Everybody's ready.
So I'd draw back,
shoot,
you know,
hit the leaf and they would just be like big smiles on their face.
It's watching that Arrow just like,
couldn't believe that Arrow just whack.
And it just,
it was,
they just want it to look at it and I'd give him the Arrow in the bow and they'd
just be holding it thinking like it was some like witchcraft.
So awesome.
They have traditional bows.
Did they make their nose?
They May.
I didn't see any,
you know,
they hunt themselves or did they,
what did they do for food?
Um,
yeah,
they've,
you know,
uh,
see,
let me think.
Well,
you're talking about the one guy,
the poacher that had really made his own sort of muzzle loader.
Yeah.
Regular,
right?
Yeah.
Those guys obviously hot,
uh,
the guys in camp,
you know,
they would eat what,
what the hunters killed basically.
And then,
uh,
but they've all hunted.
Some of them are like Rashidi who I mentioned,
he's a,
what they call a tracker.
And so they can,
what they do is they look at the tracks of the animals and they can look at them
and they can tell you whether that track was from a few hours ago,
this morning,
last night or two days ago,
just by the track.
And I'm,
you know,
I've hunted a lot,
I've seen a lot of tracks,
but when I look,
I'm like,
that's pretty fresh.
That's it.
You know,
we're full clock.
They're aging that thing by the hour essentially.
So that's what a tracker can do.
And then when you hit an animal,
if there's,
if there's a blood trail,
um,
just,
I learned so much from those guys,
you know,
and I would ask,
what are you looking at?
What's telling you that that's,
you know,
this age,
and it's just grains of sand that has fallen off the edge.
Just things like that.
So,
uh,
you know,
I think they've,
they've probably killed a lot less than they've hunted,
if that makes sense.
And they eat lions.
They,
yeah,
they'll,
they'll eat what,
they won't eat hyenas basically the Buffalo,
I'm sure they'll eat,
but they'd rather use them for bait because they're just nasty.
But definitely there's animals that they won't eat.
Um,
I'm not sure.
I couldn't tell you honestly what,
how they feel about lions because the,
like I said,
they're so revered over there.
It's just like all anybody could think of is,
you know,
we're hunting a lot of different things,
but symbol was always the topic.
It was where Simba.
And so that was what we were after.
And I don't really,
we never killed one,
so I don't really know what they would do.
Is that because they fear of those lines cause those lines we'll take people out
and they do on a regular basis.
They're right.
They will.
It's just like there's,
I've heard,
I heard stories from him over there about,
um,
the lions would come into villages and if you didn't act afraid of 'em,
they wouldn't hurt you that they,
they told stories like this.
So we'll just walk through the village and the kids,
the kids,
the kids wouldn't act afraid of them.
So the kids could be around them and watts.
Yeah.
And kids go play with the lines.
You had to wash the dishes.
Yeah.
Um,
wow.
It's,
I dunno.
In lions are different.
Lions are so dominant.
I mean I,
let's see,
I stocked to within 60 is 68 or 69 yards and I had a big male lion,
a shooter and it was quartering to me.
Obviously I just had my bow with a rifle would have been done deal.
He was a six year old mature to kind of lie and we wanted to kill as a mentioned
and I didn't have the right angle in the shot so I wasn't going to take it.
So I ended up,
I didn't shoot,
he got in the brush,
I got 50 yards from him,
but he knew I was there the whole time.
So they're not like a deer and elk,
there's just going to take off.
They're like,
the thing about it is if you,
if you get too close and you make that shot with an Arrow,
he's probably going to get you before he's dead.
You know what I mean?
And they cut though.
You can look at all the videos you want wounded.
They'll come hard a lot of times at Uw,
at whoever,
at whatever wounded them.
So what was your plan for that?
No plan.
I don't know.
It's um,
that seems like flawed.
Yeah,
I know it's a,
you know,
Ryan,
um,
he was there behind me and he had,
he had a four,
16,
which is a big gun and uh,
I trust him.
So that's the plan.
I wasn't her,
I didn't ever care about the plan to me.
I was never like,
are you okay?
You gotta you know,
I,
I never would look one time what the plan was or verify there was a plan to me.
I don't even want to say,
well,
my mind set is because people just probably just called bs.
I'm not going to say no,
I'm not going to say month.
But anyway,
it's ridiculous.
You can't say you're not going to say it and then that's it.
No,
that's a little kids.
Do they tried to trick other kids to tell her no.
When little kids do,
as I say,
I'm not going to tell you and then they don't.
Then they didn't.
They tell you no.
Then they tell you though,
when they get called out,
they'll be like,
okay,
but don't tell anybody.
I'm telling you me,
you can't say,
I'm not going to tell you because you'd call bs.
People won't call Bs.
Just speak your mind.
You won't tell anybody.
I won't tell anybody.
I won't even repeat it.
It will never leave this room.
Okay?
My stupid light thought process is if I go there,
I'm not worried about the backup plan or being covered or anything like that.
If I tried to kill the line,
but instead it kills me.
That's just the way it goes.
So you have this mindset you like,
this is just,
you're excepted reality of life.
That's it.
I mean it.
I'm trying to kill it.
If I lose and I'm on the other end of that,
this is where it goes.
That's like some intense native American talking out loud Josie Wales type shit
done.
No words of life.
People are probably just say,
oh he's,
he's full of crap this,
you know,
but I believe you,
I believe you're crazy enough to actually have that mindset.
You of saw it bear hunting.
I guess a couple of times he walked down some barriers and scared him off you.
You definitely,
that's the whole thing about the hunting on the ground.
Nobody's doing that.
Very few people were hunting bears on the ground.
But you had that whole camp doing it.
There's a lot of guys who were doing it there.
Well the thing with the bears and in you saw it is there's like this,
there's like this line.
And so what they do is they'll,
they'll stay out there at 15 yards or whatever and we're there and they know
we're there and there's like,
but then they sort of come a little closer and then they'll go back and then
they sort of come a little closer and then pretty soon there's this line that
at,
I'm thinking once they get there,
they're probably just going to come because you've let them get
there.
It's like you have to have a boundary.
So as you noticed on those bear when they would get,
I don't,
I can't remember what,
maybe it was five yards,
but I would stand up and I'd be like,
no,
like that with in holding the knife or whatever and that,
because once they're past that line is what are you going to do?
You can't let them get there.
That's the video.
We'll,
we'll play the video of you shooting this a bear,
the one that caused all the controversy,
but one of the things that's as shocking about it is not just the,
the Arrow going through the bear,
it's how fast the bear runs.
Once it gets hit,
it's like,
Geez,
that's like some Usain Bolt Shit.
Yeah,
no,
they can move,
man.
If they want to come,
we're in trouble.
But the bait thing is the,
the big controversy.
And you explained very clearly like why it's important because you have to
really identify the sex of the animal and how old the animal is.
But the weird thing is that people don't have any problem with using bait for
fish.
No.
And people don't have any problem with people going trophy fish hunting.
I caught a Marlin,
you know how many people eat Marlin's?
A few Hawaiian folks,
they'll eat them.
Apparently.
Marlin's not that bad.
It's just people think it's bad.
Yeah.
I killed a Marlin.
I caught a Marlin long time ago and uh,
they said they were going to smoke it.
The guys who own the boat,
they have a weird thing in Hawaii.
Like they'll give you some of the fish,
but you know,
they take most of the fish,
you know,
some sort of a weird,
unless you like make some sort of a previous arrangement because it's very
valuable to them,
you know.
But uh,
you know,
like,
uh,
Marlin,
like mine was about 70 pounds wasn't a big one,
but a 70 pound Marlin.
It's probably worth quite a bit of money and it's a lot of meat,
you know,
the smoke it,
but nobody has a problem with that.
But if you,
if you go and take some sort of an animal,
it's like we differentiate between a fish and an animal.
If you take a trip to Africa because you want to catch some exotic fish and eat
it on the boat,
nobody has any problem with that and like,
oh you did you eat it.
Yeah,
it was delicious.
But if you go and you say one went to Africa and shot a kudu and ate it,
like why the fuck would you go there and shoot a kudu?
Like you're not doing that for food.
You're not bringing it home to fill you,
feed your family.
They have like very rigid ideas about what you should and shouldn't do with a
mammal as opposed to what you should and shouldn't do with a fish.
Like look at these fucking,
these swamp people shows where they go and they're shooting 500 fucking
alligator a season.
They have fun.
They don't eat one of them.
They're not eating any of them.
Yeah,
they're just purely using the skins skins.
It's fine.
It's,
yeah,
for whatever reason.
Cause it's a dinosaur.
Nobody gives a shit.
Yeah.
He,
while alligators like some of the highest protein,
lowest fat,
lowest cholesterol meat you can get,
like it's really good for you.
And it's just wasting just boats full of alligator.
Yeah.
I mean I don't know some,
maybe some of them eat them.
Yeah,
probably.
But uh,
you know,
and it's,
yeah,
I guess when you talk about baiting,
when deer coming into an agricultural type setting,
that's bay tacit bake cause you're setting up on a trail they like to use to get
there or if you're,
a lot of people hunt antelope and they're coming to water [inaudible] there
you're setting up basically waters the bait.
Yeah.
So not everything fits in a perfect box is I think,
you know,
I'm not saying I'm not guilty of it either.
But uh,
I mean with hunting especially,
you know,
well I can tell you when I first started hunting,
one of the things that I said I wouldn't do is I would never bait.
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't do that and I didn't want you to bury there.
Those two things I didn't want to do.
Now I have no problem with it because I became educated sell to the devil.
That too,
I became educated will show the video.
Now,
most people would get a,
this is,
this is the video,
they got everybody mad at me and this is,
uh,
the,
the website is living the dream promotions and this is a,
our friends John and Jen up a up there in Canada.
And uh,
was this on my youtube?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Shot is only six or seven yards,
but I always take a practice shot.
So I have the target out there.
It's like a Godzilla movie.
My mouth isn't matched to shot.
Oh,
is it off?
I've seen crazy things happen a little bit.
A little bit too.
People see that bear crack back there.
Yeah.
Bear crack.
Is this a mixture of marshmallows and gelatin and all sorts of smelly things
that cam heats up so that the bear smell it
so that that target,
I'm shooting at us seven yards,
six or seven yard likes that,
like I said,
I just want to have that confidence that when a bear comes in,
I'm going to make that shot.
So even though it's a slam dunk chip shot with bow hunting,
there's no such thing.
And even though you've been doing this,
your whole lot.
So here,
look at this size of this fucking bear.
Yeah.
So that's me back there in the back wash the Arrow go through it.
This is where it's crazy.
Oh fast.
That thing moves and that sound.
But yeah,
so if it would have just veered to the,
there I am,
veered to the right instead of the left then it would have ran you over.
Yeah.
I didn't even know you were there or if it did know you were there,
it wouldn't have cared.
It was running full speed
Brent.
Yeah,
it's a no,
at that time it was just,
you know,
that was a lethal arrow.
It was just going to,
is basically going to die,
you know.
So what happens when an Arrow hits like that?
His blood pressure's dropping quickly.
It's just like your bears,
you mean dead in seconds.
They are affected immediately.
And I mean even,
you know,
you hear about people who,
they cut their for moral artery so they,
they do something,
cut something in their leg,
30 seconds.
Yeah.
When that happens is her blood pressure just drops.
And so that,
that bear at that point is not thinking about,
oh,
I'm going to identify what did that and attack it.
It's just like,
it's over basically that fast,
you know,
death sprint.
Yeah.
Yup.
I hear,
I heard a guy recently got killed by a beaver,
a beaver bid his thigh and severed his film,
or odd or,
yeah.
Nothing nuts that can happen.
Fucking beaver took a dude out.
Yeah,
you can.
Yeah.
You know,
that's,
that's a thing with,
uh,
with archery as opposed to guns,
you know,
and I had a little video the other day on my website or,
or I mean on youtube and it was just a,
you know,
an Arrow kills by hemorrhage,
uh,
just by cutting flesh and Oregon's and a rifle kills by shock generally.
And generally the,
if you hit him good with the rifle and breaking down you hip bone or whatever
else,
it's pretty,
it's pretty grizzly type thing.
But it's effective.
They're down.
An Arrow going through is more like,
they're not sure what happened.
Blood pressure drop in.
They don't necessarily feel that pain,
so to speak.
Um,
and they're dead quickly.
But two totally different things.
And what that was is I had shot a bull elk and Utah and I wasn't 100% shirt.
Certain of the shot I was hoping it was in the heart is a little lower than I
had wanted.
I wanted to shoot for the lungs,
which is a little higher up on the body.
I hit low.
Um,
just,
I made an error hit little lower than I wanted and it was hoping for the heart
and it was just kind of that process.
But we're in that video.
I explained the difference between Boeing rifle and,
and um,
you know,
you see it right there and wouldn't one thing when I was hunting Cape Buffalo in
Tanzania,
I shot this big,
the biggest bull in the herd that other animals did nothing.
He did nothing.
You couldn't tell anything happened other than he was dead pretty soon.
Wow.
Nobody ran nobody,
no excitement.
And Ryan who is with me at that time,
he's like,
I like bullied a lot better because a rifle goes off and you got a stampede and
then that bowl that you had just shot,
it's just like,
it's,
it knows something serious is going on.
And those bulls are,
you know,
they call them black death.
They're very dangerous.
So once they're injured,
even with rifles,
they use a multiple times.
I mean,
those things are so tough and so full of testosterone,
um,
1800 pounds of just solid muscle.
But what they do is they go and what they call the tall grass,
which is about 10 foot high grass.
And so you're on blood.
And those buffalo will go in there and do a little button hook and as your blood
trailing them,
if they're not mortally wounded,
like dead,
dead,
you'll be trailing at that a blood trail.
And because they did that button hooked,
they're sitting there waiting,
they'll just pound you.
And so they're really,
they kill,
they kill people every year in Africa,
a Cape Buffalo do.
And,
uh,
it's,
you know,
tough animals.
But with the bow,
uh,
we,
you know,
I'm not saying it was an easy kill because a,
there's,
they're very tough,
but it was way less dramatic way.
Everything was calm.
It was just,
I dunno,
is much different than a rifle.
Did you bring both of your bows over there and you bring the 90 pound and the 80
pound one?
I did,
yeah.
Did you shoot the buffalo with the 90?
I actually shot it with the 80.
Really because,
uh,
I did a penetration test on a,
on a hippo when one of the guys I was with killed a hippo there.
So I'm like,
hey,
how often do you ever get a chance to shoot an Arrow into a hippo 5,000 pound
hippo?
So I shot both those Bose into the hippo and actually the 80 pound carbon spider
arrow penetrated.
Neither one of them did a good job because there's big albums.
They're set up.
The setup wasn't conducive to hunting a 5,000 pound animal.
I would need a cutting tip.
Broadhead,
not the lock on the [inaudible] car has a cone tip sent or chiseled tip.
And so that has to push through until you get to the blades and you need a
thousand green Arrow with,
with a two blade broad head that doesn't have to open that hole before it gets
in.
So the point is neither one was conducive to killing a hippo.
But I measure penetration and the carbon spider with the smaller diameter
injection shaft that we shoot from Easton penetrated as much as that the heavier
a full metal jacket,
dangerous game shaft.
And so I decided,
well,
I'm just going to go with the carbon spider because I had more,
more um,
confidence in it at longer range.
And those animals were so difficult to get up on because they're living with
amongst hyenas and lions and they're hunted every single day.
And lots of lions there.
I mean,
we saw,
we probably saw,
I'm trying to think at least 10 lions I would thank,
and so it was like those,
and you,
you don't see all the lions.
So I mean,
they're hunted a lot.
So I was having a hard time getting close.
So I ended up killing that my buffalo at 62 yards with the carbon spiders 80
pound bow.
So the,
the,
the thinner diameter made a difference in the front of diamond.
Oh the Arrow does that plays a part as well as the weight?
Yeah.
Cause uh,
the thinner diameter as opposed to a thicker diameter shaft,
that's just less surface area.
So the less surfacer dragging through the wound channel,
um,
you're going to penetrate more.
What was your favorite animal?
The hunting out for go?
Um,
was it the kudu cause he ate it.
No,
now the,
that was cool.
I mean I it a big bowl,
54 orange bowl.
They had never killed a kudu.
And the fact most people kill anything over there with the bow is that water
when you're talking 54 inches,
you're talking about the length of the horns?
Yeah,
there's a spiral horns.
So you measured that spiral horn and it's 54 inches.
But most of the,
if anybody's killing anything with the bow,
it's usually at water.
And so I didn't kill anything at water.
I,
uh,
I spawns docked and Kudu,
they call them the gray ghost over there are their vision,
their antelope.
So they're like antelope here in regard to vision,
but they're tall so they can see over everything.
They're there as tall as an elk and uh,
they can see very well.
People just don't kill him.
Spawn stock with the bow.
This is a special,
Kale is a 64 yards.
But my,
I think my favorite probably,
I mean I want her to lion.
I didn't get one.
The pursuit of the lion was a memorable,
um,
probably the Cape Buffalo does because the,
the notoriety it has as being black death.
It's one of what people term the Big Five of Africa,
which is a five most dangerous animals of Africa,
an elephant,
um,
cape buffaloes in their lion,
leopard and a rhino.
And so that's the big five.
So to kill one of the big five with a bow spawn stock in a place that had never
been done.
Very special.
But what's your goals are at right now?
Like,
do you have any other places that you really want to go and hunt?
Like Africa,
I want to get lion.
I still want to get a lion.
Just some weird thing you got in the back of your head about a line.
Yeah,
I dunno.
Why just it just the test.
I don't know why.
I just want to,
I never even thought about it up until the,
it's been traveling and doing more and,
and uh,
I dunno.
So then I got it in my head and once I get something in my head,
it's just what I want to do.
But really,
and I've said this before,
I don't,
I mean I don't long to hunt anything.
I don't need to hunt any.
If I could hunt elk every year,
I'm going to be satisfied.
I love being in the mountains.
I love bull elk.
I love the challenge of trying to get in close on a big bowl and make a perfect
shot.
And that's,
if that's all I ever did,
that's enough for me.
But you've got weird things like you won't hunt Turkey.
No.
Is that weird?
Yeah,
it's weird.
Stephen.
No loves Turkey hunting.
Yeah.
It's funny to hear you.
Like the last thing I want to do is go Turkey hunting.
Well,
you know,
I've never killed a Turkey and then,
uh,
you know,
in,
in out west Turkey hunting just has never had the,
the draw that it has in the south and the east.
It's just people live for Turkey hunting back there out west is just like nobody
even ever hunted them cause we had,
we had deer,
elk bear,
we have all this big cool stuff,
predators,
big game animals to hunt.
And so Turkey was like,
why would you waste your time to county?
So that's sort of still my mindset just from that.
I guess Turkey's delicious though.
Yeah,
that's fine.
That's just fine.
Is Fine.
Wild Turkeys supposed to be better,
right than domestic Turkey.
It's a more darker meat.
Um,
it might be healthier.
It's probably not.
I like white meat personally.
Yeah.
And it's probably not going to be,
it's going to be,
I would assume tougher.
I don't even know if I've eaten wild Turkey,
but uh,
you know,
back east where basically all they are than the south.
All they have is deer in the fall and Turkey and the spring.
Yeah.
People were,
they want to hunt.
So that's what they're going to do.
You don't think it's just because they enjoy Turkey?
No,
I'm telling you,
you need to get with Rinella.
He loves Turkey hunting.
That dude loves it.
I think they,
and they always say that,
you know,
Turkey hunting is just like elk,
Connie.
It's just like Al [inaudible].
You're calling them in,
your come in and it's just like a bull coming in.
I'm like,
well yeah,
it's just like elk hunting except you can't kill a bowl.
So it's not like yell cutting.
Yeah,
it was.
Well it can't be like,
oh Connie,
you're dealing with a little skiddish bird.
They say the only difference they say elk or a book is like a 700 pound Turkey.
Well,
Turkeys,
like what's a big Turkey?
Like 30 pounds or something.
Yeah.
And yeah,
so what I say,
I'll,
you know,
Turkey hunters out there like,
hey,
if you're passionate about it,
it's awesome.
But what I always have said is,
you know the best thing that's going to happen on a Turkey hunter's you'll kill
or kill a Turkey and that's not that good.
What about like bird hunting?
Duck hunting,
pheasant hunting and that kind of stuff?
I've killed one pheasant.
Yeah.
That was the only bird bird of every kid you saw about big animals.
Yeah,
and I,
like I said,
I'm not judging anybody.
That's just me.
Of course he judging people when they're not.
When you're not judging them.
I'm going to talk off air folks.
He's going to judge the shit out of Turkey and duck and pheasant hunting
assholes and now if the those guys in the spring,
if they can't go home bear like I do hunt Turkey.
It's awesome.
Good job.
The thing about bird hunting,
it seems fun is the whole dog thing,
like the dogs,
like flush them out like when a dog points and then the,
the pheasants flying in the air and they blast amount of sky.
That looks like it would be exciting.
Yeah,
I bet it would be.
I know people,
you know,
that's a whole thing.
Just like a hunting bear with dogs is they have that connection,
the training with the dog.
And that's the same thing with the Bert.
I know people who have bird dogs and it's just like those dogs are their
partners and I totally risk,
I've been,
I've been on a,
I did one dog,
a hunt for bear and the hounds are amazing.
And then the hounds men are just does an art.
Yeah.
That's a totally different experience.
It's like you have,
like you said,
partners.
Yeah.
Those are your buddies.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
There's a lot of mountain lion hunting if they did with dogs.
Right?
Yeah.
I haven't done that either.
But I'd like to.
California,
we've got some crazy laws when it comes to hunting.
And when I say crazy,
it's because they're not designed by people who are a wildlife specialist.
They're designed by people who are more animal rights,
uh,
people.
It's,
it's like,
instead of the Department of fish and game,
they call it the department of fish and wildlife and their,
their regulations about hunting,
they've completely removed hunting for mountain mines and hunting for bears.
The bear hunting.
Now you can't do with dogs and if you can't do it with dogs and he can't do it
with Bait,
good luck.
Yeah.
You essentially have banned hunting.
Yeah,
and people don't.
Th this idea baiting
is offensive to some people and because of what we talked about earlier and the
idea of using dogs is equally offensive to some people because you're using an
animal and sticking it on an animal.
It seems sort of like a barbaric thing,
but that is really the only way to effectively hunt these animals in,
in the type of terrain that we have here in California.
So because of that,
it's a ton of bear and a ton of mountain mine and especially the mountain lion
as a kid was just attacked and Cupertino.
That's where the fucking apple campuses,
a kid,
a six year old kid was attacked by a mountain lion in front of his parents.
I mean they're,
they're out there.
There's a lot of 'em out there in California,
definitely to hone ranch if Tom said it before,
but there's a guy up there,
it's Cody bank said that he,
he has a trail camera that has,
it's over a pond.
They have 16 different mountain lions.
They've caught on this trail camera.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
No,
I mean,
yeah.
Lion's haven't been hunted here and what was 40 years?
It's been a long 30 some years.
But yeah,
it's uh,
I dunno,
they uh,
they,
you know,
a lion kills,
they say every three days,
kill something.
Deer,
elk,
hopefully not kids,
but just going to kill.
No.
Why?
People would want more lines than deer.
While you would want more predators then game animals.
It's a balance that it's,
well,
it's balanced everywhere else everywhere else except California.
I mean,
California is just so goofy with some of their laws and again,
they're not,
this is not like a rational approach that's based on real fish and,
and game people that have been doing this and calculating numbers and take an
accurate assessments and audits of the area.
This is all done by people who really don't want anybody hunting at all.
Yeah.
And they really loved it.
And League grant is a few licenses and a look.
If you keep a lot of mountain lions around,
he don't have to grant as many deer tags.
Right.
Because guess what?
There's no fucking deer
now and then that's,
that's a whole thought process behind hunting and the antis with hunting is they
want to take away or that thing.
Whoa.
Is that four of them
in Glendora.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
Back that up.
I want to see that thing again.
What creepy God damn animal.
Yeah.
Four of them I think.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
There's four of them just wandering around on a trail camera.
Oh Mike.
I said I'll pay that again.
That's,
that's going to cause some problems for deer.
That's going to cause some problems for fucking anybody.
Yeah.
Imagining if you're out there camping and you go to take a leak and you say
eight eyeballs staring back at you like that.
Not Good.
So big al too.
Yeah,
that's,
that's what people have said.
You know,
the Anti Israel,
they want to take away small chunks of our hunting rights.
So they'll say,
well this is just lions.
And then it's just this,
this baiting for bear and then it's just this and then pretty soon it's all
gone.
So that's why,
you know,
as hunters we,
I think we just need to protect our lifestyle and just keep preaching the
positive aspects of it.
So,
but I want to say before I get hate from the Turkey hunters,
I will,
I will somebody,
there's somebody want to take me Turkey hunting,
I'll go,
I'll kill on and then I'll judge whether it's like oak honey shotgun.
Either only bow,
but I can't really say.
It's not like elk hunting if I haven't done it.
That's not fair.
Well they do call them and all that.
Sounds like a good call.
Make them make a call.
Like just a little recording the Joe Rogan Turkey slash play it on your iPhone.
So I gotta I to kill one.
Then I'll make the judgment on how,
how much I like it,
I guess.
Yeah,
I would imagine.
Well,
like,
what,
what other animals are there that are like sort of underrated hunting animals?
Well,
they always say the blacktail deer back home in Oregon.
Those are,
because a lot of the country,
you know,
black blacktail or only in western Oregon or western Washington up in British
Columbia a little bit.
And then down there,
down here in Kelowna,
black tails,
right?
Yeah.
Columbia blacktail but in Oregon it's like more rain forest,
so it's very dense,
very dark.
Um,
those big bucks.
Basically they're nocturnal all year except for when they start breeding.
And even during the ruts,
still very tough to,
they don't pattern like a white tail,
so to speak,
like white tail.
A lot of guys kill him because they see these bugs on the trail cameras and they
know they're coming in the gate.
They wait for the wind to be right.
The prevailing winds.
And then they said in their tree stand and then that buck hopefully comes by and
it's,
it's patentable with black tail.
The,
uh,
the,
the legend is they're not as pattern Boland.
And I would,
I would buy into that.
And so killing a big black tail isn't on top of anybody's bucket list really are
very many people,
but it's very difficult,
very tough trophy.
You know,
all this hunting talk that we've had and the two podcasts,
it always leads to people getting excited about it.
But beginning the hunting process is extremely difficult.
Yeah.
Where to start.
I think that that's something that's a gap that we would really,
a lot of people would be really well served if we could figure out how to bridge
it.
And I've talked to Rinella about this and you've talked about like possibly
setting up a first timer's camp where you would take people to a game rich
environment.
Like maybe say like a white tail deer place where you know,
there's a lot of white,
like he won't have anything to do with high fence hunting is very admirable,
right?
Um,
so it wouldn't be that,
but something along those lines where you're going to a very game rich
environment and it,
he'll set it up for you,
bring it to a range first.
Really get you to understand a rifle safety,
gun safety.
Make sure you really,
truly understand how to squeeze the trigger,
how to,
you know,
stay down on a shot and then get you to an animal,
have you shoot an animal and then teach you how to butcher it and make like a
couple of preparations with the meat.
And to do something like this.
Start like camps that,
yeah,
like think about this a bear hunting thing that we did in Alberta.
All those guys were pretty much seasoned hunters,
but a lot of them were drawn there because of you.
Pretty much all of them.
And that's,
that's why I learned you to go on that hunt for the first bow hunt because it's,
it's basically just what we were talking about.
What are we,
what you were explaining.
It's,
it's a target rich environment.
It's a more controlled setting.
Then if you're up in the mountains after mule deer and then,
you know,
we processed the bear,
you skinned out your bear,
we cut the meat off.
So that's exactly what we did.
You know,
your first bow hunt was exactly like what you described and um,
you know most of those guys up there that were there,
they were seasoned hunters,
they hadn't bear hunted.
So that's that.
And measure how much did you learn on that hunt?
Quite a bit.
Yeah.
You learned a ton and you don't,
if you're on a like a high country mule deer hunt,
that is so difficult.
You're probably not going to kill one for a number of years.
A lot of guys get frustrated by that.
They'd like what's I wasted all this time.
I wasted all this money.
I just can't get it done.
So I like hunts like the bear hunt to get that the honeys hunting embers,
heat it up and burning hot and uh,
that's like what you're describing is perfect.
We should consider
doing something like that.
Like a camp for like a first timer camp.
Like figuring out some way to set something up.
Cause I've had so many people email me,
I've had a lot of people tweet me and 70 Facebook messages saying that they got
into hunting because of our podcast.
Because the podcast with Rinella,
which is great.
I don't know how they did it though.
I don't know how they got it.
I got into it because of Rinella.
If it wasn't for him taking me and Brian Cowen out into Montana,
I don't know how I would have started.
I don't know how to start.
And I think that that is the really difficult thing for people,
like you said as a seasoned hunter,
but you really like to do is go out by yourself.
But you're a guy with,
you know,
years and years,
decades of experience hunting for a person just starting out,
going off by themselves.
They're gonna make so many mistakes.
Well just you and I sitting on the,
on the bear bay.
I mean,
remember the talks we had about movement,
you know,
moving
edge detection,
right?
They see any movement they see,
Cause like I said,
we were sitting there and so you'd see what time it was or you,
you want to take a photo and I,
and I said,
you can do all that just slower move,
like to not a predator.
Right.
So,
but when you're,
when you don't have somebody there with you,
you make all those mistakes and then it just elongates that learning curve.
So I would,
I would love to take first some first time hunter and sit there with them just
like with you and just,
you know,
I know,
I'm not saying I have all the answers or whatever.
I've just made a lot of mistakes.
Right.
You know,
so I've learned,
I don't want people to have to make all the mistakes I did.
And um,
I practiced for a long time,
but it wasn't really that long.
It was only like six months between the time we met in a time we started at that
camp.
Um,
but through that six months I was steady shooting arrows basically on a daily
basis.
Diligent.
Wow.
How much time do you think someone would need from being introduced to archery
to going in a controlled environment,
a bear hunt like that?
Um,
you know,
if it just,
the thing is,
is there's so much more to bow hunting than just shooting paper,
you know,
and it's just that mindset and the,
and the respect thing.
But it's so hard to learn that when you haven't done it.
So it was just like,
it's like how do you measure all that?
But with a bow,
killing an animal with a bow,
it the biggest thing for new guys,
just what you did.
It's just being proficient with your weapon.
You know,
being proficient with your weapon,
knowing where you're going to hit and having the confidence to make that shot
because,
um,
even though it is close range,
I mean,
you saw me take a practice shot at seven yards,
even though I've done it probably millions of times and killed many,
many bear still.
I'm still diligent in my process.
Well,
we actually talked about that because the day after we went hunting and I got
that bear,
we went again and you actually put it in my head that it's easy to,
once you've done it,
then take it for granted.
So you have to maintain that same mindset that you have the very first day when
you made the perfect shot.
And I thought that was a very important point that you said to me,
because I know that people do go,
I've done this before and then you could screw up and wound.
And that's another thing.
Um,
another thing I remember sharing with you is the bear you killed,
we would need to get a good look at it.
So he had been in,
we wanted to make sure it was a bor,
a big bore,
like we want to kill.
And so we had,
it had been in and been in and I said,
I go and you didn't shoot it.
But then once we got to look at it and we were like,
okay,
that is the bear we want to kill because it can take awhile to see if it's a
board.
They're not alike,
doesn't have antlers.
So you have to look at,
you know,
basically it's the,
the hair off the penis sheath is what it is.
But,
uh,
and that is with binocular.
So once I said,
once we decide or once you decide that's going to be a bear,
you're gonna shoot,
your emotions are probably going to get going.
Because it had been,
it had been from just being just kind of enjoying it being closed or just kind
of that moment to all of a sudden now I'm going to kill an animal that changes
everything it did to your body just is like,
okay,
this is,
this is a real deal now.
And so that's,
yeah,
just that type of thing.
Having somebody there or having that conversation allows people to,
to process it on their own.
And you know,
in my,
in my book back country bow hunting,
that was the,
one of the most popular chapters that have had,
as I wrote a chapter on fear,
no guy ever wants to talk about being afraid or being,
you know,
they're afraid of the dark or scared of being attacked by.
But so I talked about that and I said,
hey,
when I was first in the mountains by myself,
I was afraid.
And so when people read that and they're like,
they think about it.
And then they're in that position,
they're just like,
this is normal.
This is normal.
And so when,
when we can,
um,
talk about things like the experience of,
okay,
now I'm going to kill the,
kill the bear,
now it's time to get it done.
And you know what,
you can kind of anticipate what that's going to feel like.
You're just going to be that much more deadly,
more lethal.
And uh,
not to one thing is I was in the gym the other day and this,
this guy was telling me,
he's like,
he has one of my old Bose just from years ago and he's like,
he was calm.
He goes,
he goes,
I almost got a bull.
And I'm like,
what?
What happened buddy?
He's like 35 yards.
He come in,
he's bugling and I had your bow and I'm standing there watching me,
he's 35 yards and he's right there.
He goes,
and I was shaking so bad.
I don't even know how I could have shot it.
And I'm like,
that's normal.
That's how everybody is.
But so that's where it is,
is in that moment shaking.
But still,
okay,
I need to be in control and I need to do everything that I practice and make
that that shot.
That's a lot of people get that shaking and,
and then they never get to the other part.
The precision part that's,
that's difficult.
Well,
controlling emotions is very difficult and almost anything you do that's d,
anything you do that's important to you is going to come with a surge of
adrenaline or sure.
Surge of nerves of anxiety and it's just about maintaining your breathing and
staying calm.
And there was a definitely for me,
a big difference between like that's the bear.
Like okay,
Ooh,
but it helped that you had already prepared me for that.
Right,
right.
Well I'm glad you did.
Great.
Let us know about them.
It's great being your friend.
It's great learning from you.
I appreciate it very much and it's great that we can expose so many people to
this.
Well thanks for giving me the platform.
I feel lucky to be in la in this mess.
Seven city and talking to you guys for sure.
Oh,
so for John and Jen's a website,
it's live in l I v.
I n.
The dream productions.
That is a,
that's their website.
L I.
V.
I n the dream.
And that's the place we went to.
If you want to go.
And if you want to experience bear hunting in that environment,
you can do no better than John and Jen.
They're great folks and they have a,
uh,
incredibly bare rich environment.
And if you're a first time bow hunter,
it's the way to go.
It really is.
And uh,
you could fall cam,
you could follow him on Twitter even though he doesn't know his Twitter
password.
All of his Facebook stuff goes to his Twitter and your,
your Facebook page campaigns to our Cameron Hanes.
Yeah.
Cameron Hanes on Twitter.
Cameron Hanes on Facebook.
Thanks brother.
Really appreciate it.
Thank you Joe Cameron.
I'll do it.
I get to tell you.
All right,
my friends,
we'll be back next week until that much love.
See you soon.
Hmm.